Some things in your life you decide you're never going to talk about. For Jules, it was what her youth pastor did to her long ago when she was a teenager in Texas. She tried to put it aside -- tried to move on. But then #MeToo happened with so many more women reporting men who'd assaulted or harassed them.
有些事情，你决定这辈子绝口不提。对朱尔斯（Jules）来说，那是她十几岁在德克萨斯州时，她的青年牧师对她所做的事。她试图将其抛诸脑后——试图继续生活。但后来“我也是”（#MeToo）运动爆发了，越来越多的女性站出来举报曾侵犯或骚扰过她们的男性。
And Matt Lauer had been on the front cover of the USA Today, and I thought, oh my goodness. It inspired me so much that that very day, I wrote to my abuser, who was now a pastor at a megachurch.
当时马特·劳尔（Matt Lauer）的照片登上了《今日美国》的头版，我心想，天哪。这给了我极大的鼓舞，就在那天，我写信给了那个侵犯我的人，他当时正是一家大型教会的牧师。
He never responded, so she wrote a blog post about it, thinking, you know, maybe 100 people would see it. That was not the moment we were in. It became international news, and because of #MeToo, there were consequences that would have been unimaginable just a year before. The former youth pastor resigned from his job at the megachurch.
他从不回应，于是她写了一篇博客文章，心想，大概会有100个人看到吧。但那时的环境早已不同。这件事成了国际新闻，得益于“我也是”运动，出现了一些仅仅一年前还无法想象的后果。那位前青年牧师辞去了他在大型教会的工作。
Things changed for Jules, too. All of a sudden, lots of women were calling her for advice on how to handle what they were going through, and she found a lot of meaning in those conversations. She set up a nonprofit that funds therapy for women who've been sexually assaulted, but there were aftershocks from her #MeToo moment that she never could have guessed, like with her three daughters. There's this conversation a year or two after she came forward.
朱尔斯的生活也随之改变。突然间，许多女性打电话向她寻求建议，询问如何处理她们正在经历的事情，她在这些对话中找到了许多意义。她成立了一个非营利组织，为曾遭受性侵的女性提供治疗资金。但她的“我也是”时刻也带来了一些她未曾预料到的余波，比如对她三个女儿的影响。在她公开真相后的一两年里，曾有过这样一段对话。
One of them said, mommy, why do you have to be a survivor? And that just broke my heart.
其中一个女儿说，妈妈，你为什么非要做一个幸存者？这话真的让我心碎。
And how old was she when she said that?
她当时多大？
Probably about six or seven, and I had to explain, sweetheart, I didn't choose for this to happen. I didn't choose to be a survivor. All my girls have seen me in tears over the years because of all this, and they also know that it takes up a lot of time.
大概六七岁吧，我不得不解释，宝贝，我没有选择让这一切发生。我没有选择成为一个幸存者。多年来，我的女孩们因为这一切见过我流泪，她们也知道这占据了我很多时间。
Right, because she sees you counseling other people and talking to people about it, and
对，因为她看到你在为其他人提供咨询，还在和别人谈论这件事，而且
Right. You know, I'll say, hold on, honey, I'm on the phone with a survivor. I've got an advocacy meeting at 1 o'clock or whatever, and so they see it as taking time away from them. But they also see the emotional toll it can take.
对。你知道，我会说，等一下，宝贝，我正在和一位幸存者通电话。我下午一点有个倡导会议什么的，所以她们觉得这占用了她们的时间。但她们也看到了这可能带来的情感创伤。
Five years after the #MeToo explosion, some powerful and well known men lost their jobs. A few went to prison. Over 20 states passed laws to make workplaces safer. Some changed statutes of limitations so people have more time to report sexual harassment and assault. That change, by the way, is why E. Jean Carroll was able to sue former President Trump recently.
“我也是”运动爆发五年后，一些有权势且知名的男性失去了工作。几个人进了监狱。超过20个州通过了法律，使工作场所变得更加安全。一些州修改了诉讼时效，让人们有更多时间来举报性骚扰和性侵。顺便说一句，正是因为这种改变，E. Jean Carroll 最近才得以起诉前总统特朗普。
Lots of employers adopted new HR policies, introduced more trainings. There was a bump in reporting for a while, but you know what we haven't heard that much about? How this has played out in the lives of the women who stepped forward and went public with their stories. I and a few of my coworkers have been talking to women like that, and one of the things I thought was so striking was the small ways that the aftermath of coming forward continues to pop up in their daily lives. For starters, a few of them told me that any time they meet someone new, even years later, they do this calculation in their head -- what do they know about me? What have they read, if anything? It's stressful.
许多雇主采取了新的人力资源政策，引入了更多培训。有一段时间举报率确实有所上升，但你知道我们还没怎么听到过什么吗？那就是那些站出来并公开自己故事的女性，她们的生活后来怎么样了。我和我的几位同事一直在采访这样的女性，其中一点让我印象深刻：公开真相后的余波，以细微的方式不断出现在她们的日常生活中。首先，她们中有几个人告诉我，无论什么时候见到新朋友，即使是几年后，她们脑子里也会进行一番盘算——他们对我了解多少？如果他们读过什么的话，读的是什么？这让人压力很大。
Take Tanya Selvaratnam. She says she felt tremendous relief when she spoke out in 2018 about her abusive relationship with the New York State Attorney General, Eric Schneiderman, and he stepped down hours after her story came out. But in the time since then, she still gets reminded of it in certain kinds of social interactions.
以坦尼娅·塞尔瓦拉特南（Tanya Selvaratnam）为例。她说，2018年当她公开自己与纽约州总检察长埃里克·施奈德曼（Eric Schneiderman）的虐待关系时，她感到了巨大的解脱，而在她的故事曝光几小时后，他就辞职了。但自那以后，在某些社交互动中，她仍然会被提醒想起这件事。
One example is I had gone on a few dates with a man who was wonderful and so kind, and we got together one night and he asked how my day had been, and there was an essay I had written, which had just come out in Elle magazine. And he asked if he could read it, and as I was saying what I had been doing that day, I realized, oh wait, we haven't talked about my story because it's not something that I lead with, and he wanted to read it. And I said, sure, and so then he looked it up and he read it. He sent me a beautiful note, thanking me for sharing my story and he's sorry for what I went through, and then I never heard from him again.
举个例子，我和一个很棒、很善良的男人约会了几次，一天晚上我们聚在一起，他问我这一天过得怎么样，我当时有一篇文章刚在《Elle》杂志上发表。他问他能不能读一读，当我在说我那天做的事情时，我意识到，哦等等，我们还没谈过我的故事，因为这不是我主动提起的话题，而他想读一读。我说，当然可以，于是他就查到了那篇文章并读了它。他发给我一条很温馨的信息，感谢我分享我的故事，并对我所经历的一切表示遗憾，然后我就再也没收到他的消息了。
What did you take from that?
你从中得到了什么启示？
A good guy, but my story made him uncomfortable. Like I hope that people recognize it was a sliver of my life. It was a short sliver of my life, and that there's a whole life before and after that I have forged separate from that sliver.
他是个好人，但我的故事让他感到不舒服。我希望人们能认识到，那只是我生命中的一小片。那是我生命中很短的一小片，在那之前和之后，我有完整的生活，是我独立于那一小片之外锻造出来的。
Calling around, we heard about women switching careers, falling into debt from legal fees, but we also heard specific things that were so individual to each person. An associate professor at Tufts dental school reported a coworker, and then after, she met with her supervisor about it, and the way that the supervisor responded was so upsetting to her that now, the clothes she wore to those meetings. She says she can't wear those clothes anymore or even look at them. One woman, a wildland firefighter with the US Forest Service, told us that she expected after she reported that her bosses would start training the staff differently. They didn't. So now that's something she does for her co-workers -- kind of DIY.
我们四处打听，听说有些女性改行了，因法律费用陷入债务，但我们也听到了一些非常个人的具体经历。塔夫茨牙医学院的一位副教授举报了一位同事，事后她就此事与上司会面，而上司的反应让她非常难过，以至于她在那几次会议上穿的衣服，她说她再也不能穿了，甚至连看都不敢看。一位美国林务局的野外消防员告诉我们，她原以为举报后，老板们会开始以不同的方式培训员工。但他们没有。所以现在这是她为同事们做的事情——算是自助式的吧。
Another woman, a truck driver in California, Laura Zuniga, came forward with the expectation that something would happen to the man that she reported. When it didn't, when he kept his job, she shut herself in a room for a while, stopped cooking for her three daughters, stopped taking them out, stopped being a mom. They'd come to her door and she'd tell them to go make themselves cereal or a sandwich. She says it especially got to the two older girls.
另一位女性，加州的卡车司机劳拉·祖尼加（Laura Zuniga），站出来时以为她举报的那个男人会受到惩罚。但当什么都没发生，当他保住了工作时，她把自己关在房间里好一段时间，不再为她的三个女儿做饭，不再带她们出去，不再做一个妈妈。她们会来到她的门前，她就叫她们自己去弄麦片或三明治吃。她说这尤其让两个大女儿感到受伤。
Now they're very shy. The two older ones are very shy. They don't want to go nowhere. Somebody comes, they ring the doorbell -- they run to the room.
现在她们非常害羞。那两个大的非常害羞。她们哪儿也不想去。有人来了，按门铃——她们就跑进房间。
And they weren't like that before this?
在这之前她们不是这样的吗？
No. Somebody came over, they'll come out like nothing. Now they just wait for the people to leave.
不是。有人来串门，她们会像没事人一样出来。现在她们只是等着人走。
Yeah.
嗯。
They stick to themselves. I think they lost maybe some part of their childhood.
她们变得孤僻了。我想她们可能失去了一部分童年。
When Chanel Miller reported what happened to her, she wound up in front of a jury. It was a pretty well-known case. She was known as Emily Doe, and then came out with her name after #MeToo happened. A swimmer at Stanford University named Brock Turner sexually assaulted her while she was unconscious. She'd been drinking at a party. She says the experience of telling that story in a courtroom has stayed with her in a bunch of ways, including this one.
当香奈儿·米勒（Chanel Miller）举报所发生的事情时，她最终站在了陪审团面前。那是一个非常著名的案件。她当时被称为“艾米莉·多伊”（Emily Doe），在“我也是”运动发生后，她公开了自己的名字。斯坦福大学一名叫布洛克·特纳（Brock Turner）的游泳选手在她不省人事时性侵了她。她在派对上喝了酒。她说在法庭上讲述那个故事的经历以多种方式留在了她的脑海里，包括这一点。
If it's 10:00 PM in New York, which is pretty early for New York, and I'm trying to decide whether I'm going to take the subway or a taxi home, in order to make that decision, I tell the story of the evening back to myself. So if I went to a book reading and had some champagne, I think, you know, I sound like a reasonable, credible person. I'm going to take a risk and take the subway. The subway is assumed to be riskier than the taxi.
如果现在是纽约晚上10点，对纽约来说时间还挺早，我正在决定是坐地铁回家还是打出租车，为了做出这个决定，我会在脑海里重温那天晚上的故事。如果我当时去参加了一个读书会，喝了点香槟，我想，你知道，我听起来像个理智、可信的人。我要冒个险，坐地铁。地铁被认为比出租车风险更高。
If I went to a friend's birthday party and I was wearing a bear costume and drank Hennessy out of a coconut and won a hula hooping contest, I think, you know, that person sounds a little bit more unhinged. I don't feel like explaining that to a jury, so I'm going to take a taxi.
如果当时我去参加朋友的生日派对，穿了一套熊的服装，从椰子里喝着轩尼诗，还赢了呼啦圈比赛，我想，你知道，那个人听起来有点疯疯癫癫的。我可不想向陪审团解释这些，所以我还是打出租车吧。
Wow. Because you really play out the whole thing in your head as do I want to say this in court someday?
哇。因为你真的在脑子里预演这一切，想着我以后想在法庭上说这个吗？
Yes.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
And what's sad about that is that I am not thinking about my own safety. I'm thinking about how to increase my chances of being believed.
最可悲的是，我考虑的不是我自己的安全。我考虑的是如何增加我被相信的几率。
Today on our show, we have the story of somebody who came forward, and what happened to her next has never been told. In fact, she's only been known as Jane Doe, and she's remarkable in a few ways. First of all, she is so young. She's just a teenager, and she spoke out about one of the most powerful people in her state. And in this case, the story that the public knows is very, very different from what actually happened to her. In some ways, the public story is the opposite of her experience of it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目讲述了一个站出来的女性的故事，她接下来发生的事情从未被讲述过。事实上，她一直只被称为“简·多伊”（Jane Doe），她在几个方面都很不寻常。首先，她非常年轻。她只是个十几岁的孩子，却敢于站出来指控她所在州最有权势的人之一。而且在这个案例中，公众所知道的故事与她实际经历的事情非常、非常不同。在某种程度上，公众所知的版本与她本人的经历恰恰相反。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One. The Intern.
第一幕：实习生。
So the person our show is about today was a 19-year-old intern in the Idaho state legislature, and I should say before I go any further that there is no way to discuss what happened to her without talking about sexual violence. Take that as a heads up for what's to follow.
所以今天节目中的主角是一位19岁的爱达荷州议会实习生，在继续讲述之前，我必须声明，如果不讨论性暴力，就无法谈论她身上发生的事情。请把这当作接下来内容的预警。
In 2021, this teenager reported that a state representative twice her age raped her. She came forward with her story, and then so many things went differently than they would have before #MeToo. Idaho's state house had put in place a basic reporting system for complaints like this. The incident was investigated, there were consequences -- all within a month and a half. The house put on a hearing and came to a fast decision.
2021年，这位十几岁的女孩举报一位比她大两倍的州议员强奸了她。她站出来讲述了自己的故事，随后发生了很多与“我也是”运动前完全不同的事情。爱达荷州众议院建立了一套针对此类投诉的基本举报系统。该事件得到了调查，也有了后果——这一切都在一个半月内完成。众议院举行了听证会，并迅速做出了决定。
Committee, we have a motion. I will summarize that motion. Our motion is that representative von Ehlinger should be censured with the following restrictions and conditions. One, that he be immediately suspended without pay or benefits. Two, that he must immediately vacate his office in the capitol and not return to capitol grounds for the remainder of the 66th Idaho legislature. And three...
委员会成员，我们有一项动议。我将总结该动议。我们的动议是，冯·埃林格（von Ehlinger）议员应受到谴责，并附加以下限制和条件。第一，立即停职，不发工资或福利。第二，立即搬出他在议会大厦的办公室，并在第66届爱达荷州议会余下的任期内不得返回议会大厦。第三……
The committee vote was unanimous. They then called for a vote from the full House to expel the representative. He immediately resigned. So you know, that's change right, post #MeToo? State legislators talked about how proud they were of their ability to do the right thing so quickly. They praised their colleagues around the hearing as masterful. One of our producers, Miki Meek, watched all this happen back then, and she had a question -- namely, what was all this like for Jane Doe? Here's Miki.
委员会的投票是一致通过的。他们随后要求全体众议院投票驱逐该议员。他立即辞职了。所以你知道，这就是变化，对吧，“我也是”运动之后？州议员们谈论着他们对自己能如此迅速地做出正确决定感到多么自豪。他们赞扬同事们在听证会上的表现非常老练。我们的制片人之一，美纪·米克（Miki Meek），当时目睹了这一切，她有一个疑问——也就是说，这一切对于“简·多伊”来说是怎样的？请听美纪的报道。
I live just south of Boise, and the story of Jane Doe was all over the news. There was a public ethics hearing in the Idaho House. I watched her answer questions.
我住在博伊西市南边，“简·多伊”的故事上了所有新闻。爱达荷州众议院举行了公开的道德听证会。我看着她回答问题。
Did you make a report to Boise Police Department that on March 9th, you had been raped by Representative von Ehlinger?
你是否曾向博伊西警察局报案，称3月9日被冯·埃林格议员强奸？
Yes.
是的。
The first thing I noticed -- Jane Doe was young. Just a teenager. Just out of high school. They had her behind these giant black curtains up on a dais at the very front of the room. These big black curtains that hung off some tall metal frames were supposed to shield her identity, which was weird because nothing was being done to disguise her actual voice. I couldn't stop thinking, what is happening here? It felt very Handmaid's Tale, like she was on trial.
我注意到的第一件事——简·多伊很年轻。只是个十几岁的人。刚高中毕业。他们把她安置在房间最前方的高台上，后面挂着巨大的黑布帘。这些挂在金属架上的大黑布帘本来是为了保护她的身份，这很奇怪，因为没有任何措施来掩盖她真实的声音。我无法停止思考，这到底是怎么回事？感觉非常像《使女的故事》，好像她是在受审。
Did you tell him to stop?
你告诉他停下来了吗？
I said no.
我说不。
Did you say other things that indicated no?
你有没有说过其他表示拒绝的话？
Multiple. Multiple different reiterations. I even tried to just convince him to not, telling him I wasn't on birth control and I hadn't shaved myself or -- things to make me seem unappeasable, you know? And he just continued.
说了多次。反复重申了好几次。我甚至试图说服他停下，告诉他我没有避孕，我也没有刮毛或者——做些让自己看起来让人没胃口的事情，你懂吗？但他还是继续。
So that's a pretty intense thing to hear a teenager recounting behind a black curtain. And then here's the part that really made me wonder what this was all like for Jane. Something happened after she finished her testimony.
所以，在黑布帘后面听到一个十几岁的女孩讲述这一切，感觉非常强烈。然后就是这一部分，真正让我好奇这一切对于“简”来说意味着什么。在她作证结束后，发生了一件事。
Thank you, Ms. Doe. You are excused.
谢谢你，多伊小姐。你可以退席了。
After she exited the room, the mics picked up a faint scream.
在她离开房间后，麦克风捕捉到了一声微弱的尖叫。
[SCREAM]
[尖叫声]
It was hers. Some of the representatives conducting the hearing looked around in confusion for a split second, and then got back to work calling up witnesses. Watching this back in 2021, just four years after the #MeToo movement broke, I assumed Jane Doe was part of a younger generation of women who were reporting sexual violence. But who knows? She was literally invisible at the hearing. What was it like for her back behind that curtain and what was that scream? I wanted to find out more about what exactly happened to Jane Doe.
那是她的尖叫。主持听证会的一些议员茫然地环顾四周，然后又回到工作岗位，传唤证人。在2021年回顾这一切，也就是“我也是”运动爆发仅仅四年后，我以为“简·多伊”属于年轻一代举报性暴力的女性。但谁知道呢？她在听证会上实际上是隐形的。在帘子后面对于她来说是什么样子的？那声尖叫又是什么？我想找出“简·多伊”到底发生了什么。
I reached out to Jane Doe through her lawyers after the hearing to see if she wanted to share more. Five months later, I noticed a couple of missed calls on my phone. I called back. It was Jane. She'd been calling me and not leaving messages, trying to reach me out of the blue because she worried I'd try to record our call without her knowing. She said she was feeling paranoid.
听证会后，我通过她的律师联系了“简”，看她是否愿意分享更多信息。五个月后，我注意到手机上有几个未接来电。我回了过去。是“简”。她之前一直给我打电话却不留言，试图冷不丁地联系我，因为她担心我会瞒着她录音。她说她感到很偏执。
When I finally met Jane in person, she was very direct. She'd been seeing all these people talking about her and finally wanted to give her side of it. She had a lot to say about every part of the process that led her up to the seat behind the black curtain. She just turned 20. She was really funny -- a total goofball. She has a membership at a trampoline gym.
当我终于见到“简”本人时，她非常直率。她看到那么多人都在谈论她，终于想给出自己的说法。对于导致她坐在黑布帘后面的过程中的每一部分，她都有很多话要说。她刚满20岁。她真的很有趣——是个十足的“开心果”。她在蹦床健身房办了会员。
I go like four times a week.
我一周大概去四次。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I love it there.
我爱死那儿了。
Her favorite? The dodgeball zone.
她最喜欢的是？躲避球区。
And I just love messing up kids.
我就是喜欢折磨那些小孩。
You mean like nailing them with a ball?
你是说用球砸他们？
I love being a big sister, and I don't get the chance to be a big sister a lot, so when I get a chance to just, like, go annihilate some little, like, nine year olds, I will.
我喜欢当大姐姐，我没太多机会当大姐姐，所以只要有机会去蹂躏一下那些九岁大的孩子，我肯定会去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They're always like, ah, you got me! I love kids, you know?
他们总是说，啊，你打中我了！我爱孩子，你懂吗？
Jane's a big sister to many younger siblings. She's always teasing them with fart jokes. But the main thing that really stood out to me about her is just how much she loves nerding out about the state legislature.
“简”有很多弟弟妹妹。她总是用放屁笑话来逗他们。但关于她，真正让我印象深刻的是她有多喜欢钻研州议会事务。
I have pictures and I would love to show you. I always have a bunch of pictures of the state house -- the state house is so pretty.
我有照片，我很想给你看。我总是拍很多议会大厦的照片——州议会大厦太美了。
She pulled up a photo of the Idaho state flag hanging from the rotunda.
她调出了一张爱达荷州州旗悬挂在圆形大厅的照片。
You got the tree. You got the deer. And I mean, like, I think it's beautiful.
你看这棵树。你看这头鹿。我的意思是，我觉得这很美。
Her favorite pictures were of her cubicle -- a big wood desk, swivel chair, and her own name plaque.
她最喜欢的照片是关于她的隔间——一张大木桌、旋转椅，还有她自己的名字牌。
And it was really funny, too. Like, the sergeant at arms put my name in all caps on it because she said then that people would find me easier.
这太搞笑了。守卫把我的名字全部用大写印在上面，因为她说这样人们更容易找到我。
Had you ever had an office before?
你以前有过办公室吗？
No, I'd never had my own office. I was shook.
没有，我从没拥有过自己的办公室。我惊呆了。
What did you love about that?
你喜欢那一点？
Honestly, if I will just get straight to really what it made me feel, I felt like I was walking on gold. Like, literally my entire family -- I'm the first one to ever work for the government, right? I mean, yeah, I was just proud of myself.
老实说，如果我要直接说出那一刻我的感受，我觉得自己走在金子上面。真的，我整个家族——我是第一个为政府工作的人，对吧？我的意思是，是的，我只是为自己感到骄傲。
The capitol had been a surreal place for Jane to find herself in. Just a few years earlier, she was a pregnant high school freshman trying to figure her life out. She started making money by working field jobs on potato and corn farms, and picked up a night shift at Panda Express. As a sophomore, she enrolled herself in a special high school for teen parents and started volunteering in domestic violence shelters. She quickly became the kind of model overachiever who gets voted most likely to become President of the United States.
对于“简”来说，国会大厦是一个超现实的地方。就在几年前，她还是个怀孕的高中新生，试图理清自己的生活。她开始在土豆和玉米农场打工赚钱，还去熊猫快餐（Panda Express）上了夜班。高二时，她为自己报名了一所针对青少年家长的特殊高中，并开始在家庭暴力收容所做志愿者。她很快就成为了那种被选为“最有希望成为美国总统”的模范尖子生。
When Jane was a senior in high school, she signed up to be a page in the Idaho House of Representatives. She ran errands for a special committee and was celebrated on the local news for it.
当“简”读高三时，她报名成为了爱达荷州众议院的传令员。她为一个特别委员会跑腿，并因此上了当地新闻。
The first teen mom to serve as a page in the state house. Her work in domestic violence programs brought her here to learn more about the legislative process.
第一位在州议会服务的青少年妈妈。她在家庭暴力项目中工作，使她来到这里进一步了解立法过程。
Jane learned the steps on how to make a bill, and for fun, sat in on meetings of the Judiciary and Rules Committee. She liked tracking all the different drafts of bills that got introduced and seeing what happened to them. She'd grown up with an abusive dad and then had a boyfriend who was violent with her. Seeing firsthand just how badly the criminal process worked for victims, she wondered why it wasn't better. And now that she'd seen the work of a lawmaker up close, she decided that's what she wanted for herself.
“简”学习了如何起草法案的步骤，为了好玩，她旁听了司法与规则委员会的会议。她喜欢跟踪所有提交的不同法案草案，看看它们会有什么结果。她在虐待父亲的阴影下长大，后来又有一个对她施暴的男朋友。亲眼看到刑事程序对受害者有多么不友好，她想知道为什么不能做得更好。现在她近距离看到了立法者的工作，她决定那也是她想要的人生。
So after the page program was over, after she graduated from high school, Jane decided she had to get back to the House. She applied for an internship, and to get it, she needed to find a representative who would sponsor her.
所以传令员计划结束后，她高中毕业了，简决定一定要回到众议院。她申请了实习机会，为了得到它，她需要找到一位议员来赞助她。
So I just reached out to everybody I could that I knew, you know, because you could find their contact online. You can find their email and stuff, so I just was, like, sending emails like, hey.
所以我联系了我能联系到的所有人，你知道，因为你可以上网找到他们的联系方式。你可以找到他们的电子邮件什么的，所以我只是发邮件说，嘿。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I was like, Hi, I don't know if you remember me. I was a page last year. I don't know if you remember on your committee -- blah, blah, blah, depending on who I was talking to. But basically, I'm just like, Hey, you know, I'm really interested in coming back this year and learning more. I think I can benefit you and benefit me at the same time. I have a lot that I want to learn. Like, I wanted to be there, you know? Like, I wanted to learn.
我写道，嗨，不知道你是否还记得我。我去年做过传令员。不知道你是否还记得在你们委员会——巴拉巴拉，取决于我联系的人。但基本意思就是，嘿，你知道，我对今年回来学习更多东西非常感兴趣。我觉得我能给你带来帮助，同时也让自己获益。有很多我想学的东西。我是说，我想在那里，你懂吗？我想学习。
She got an internship with a Republican representative -- not von Ehlinger, the one she reported for raping her. It was another one. She started at the beginning of 2021 -- a desk of her own on the ground floor of the Idaho State Capitol. She felt like this was the beginning of something much bigger.
她获得了一位共和党议员的实习机会——不是那个被她举报强奸的冯·埃林格。是另一位。她于2021年初开始工作——在爱达荷州议会大厦的一楼拥有了自己的办公桌。她觉得这是某样更宏大事业的开端。
Jane remembers running into Representative von Ehlinger pretty soon after the 2021 legislative session started. She wasn't interning for him. He was just another Republican representative -- a very new one. I reached out to von Ehlinger and his lawyer for comment, but didn't get a response. He hasn't been talking to the press. It was his first term in the House. He was a substitute teacher from Northern Idaho.
“简”记得2021年立法会议开始后不久就遇到了冯·埃林格议员。她并不是他的实习生。他只是另一位共和党议员——一位非常新的议员。我联系了冯·埃林格及其律师请求置评，但没有得到回复。他一直没有接受媒体采访。这是他在众议院的第一任期。他是北爱达荷州的一名代课老师。
There was a few times when I'd walk out of committee and he was, like, there and I'd just -- you know, I smile and wave at everybody. And then he just kind of stared at me, and I was like, I'm just going to keep walking. And then I think the second time -- there was a bunch of people like right where the entrance was to go get to my office. There was a bunch of people there, so I'm just kind of like lingering, and then Ehlinger was like, Oh, how are you? I had my intern badge, and he was just like, Who do you intern for? And I was like, Well, I'm just, I have my own office over here, and --
有几次我走出委员会，他就站在那里，我只是——你知道，我微笑着向大家挥手。然后他就一直盯着我，我心想，我还是继续走吧。然后我想第二次——入口处聚集了一堆人，那是通往我办公室的必经之路。那里有一堆人，所以我只是徘徊了一下，然后埃林格说，噢，你好吗？我挂着实习生的徽章，他就直接问，你为谁实习？我说，嗯，我有自己的办公室在这里，然后——
He was holding some cookies shaped like Idaho.
他手里拿着几个爱达荷州形状的饼干。
I was like, oh, those are cool-looking cookies. And he was like, oh, do you want them? And I was like, Sure. Like, I'm just going to my office right now. I'll put them there. And he's like, OK, and just like follows me back.
我说，噢，这些饼干看起来很酷。他说，噢，你想要吗？我说，当然。就像，我正要去办公室，我会把它们放在那儿。他说，好吧，然后就跟着我回去了。
What did you make of that at the time?
你当时怎么看这件事？
Well, I mean, I wasn't too weirded out by it. I was just like, OK, like it's just another one of them. Whatever, it's just another sir. There's a lot of sirs in there, OK. There's sirs everywhere.
嗯，我的意思是，我并没有觉得太奇怪。我只是想，好吧，这只是他们中的另一个。没关系，只是另一个先生。那儿有很多先生，好吗。到处都是先生。
S-I-R?
S-I-R（先生）？
Yeah, sir. It's just because you've got to say sir.
对，先生。就因为你得称呼别人为先生。
How would you define what a sir is?
你会如何定义什么是“先生”？
Like literally suits -- like men in suits.
就像字面意思上的西装——穿西装的男人们。
Jane adds that sir is the kind of male representative who would text her late at night about a non-urgent work question, who'd keep her in his office too long, and who she overheard talking with other sirs about whether she looked better in her tan skirt or her striped one. She told me there were a lot of sirs in the House. Sometimes she'd get this creeping feeling that they would look at her and think, wow, how exotic. Jane's Hispanic. Many of the other women working in the capitol were blonde and white.
“简”补充说，所谓“先生”就是那种会在深夜给她发无关紧要的工作短信的男议员，会把她长时间留在办公室里，她还会听到他们和其他“先生”谈论她穿那条棕褐色裙子还是条纹裙子更好看。她告诉我，议会里有很多“先生”。有时她会产生一种毛骨悚然的感觉，觉得他们看着她时心想，哇，真有异国情调。“简”是拉丁裔。国会大厦里许多其他女性是白人金发。
After von Ehlinger gave her those Idaho-shaped cookies, Jane says he was suddenly walking by her desk multiple times a day to make small talk. He gave her his phone number. Food seemed to be the main currency of flirting for a lot of the sirs. Jane says they were constantly offering her snacks from their mini fridges or dropping off lunch.
冯·埃林格给她那些爱达荷州形状的饼干后，“简”说他突然每天几次走过她的办公桌寒暄。他给了她电话号码。对于很多“先生”来说，食物似乎是调情的主要货币。简说他们不断地从迷你冰箱里拿零食给她，或者送来午餐。
At times, all this free food was nice. Jane's internship was unpaid. She was supporting herself and her three-year-old son with a second job. She worked the overnight shift at a domestic violence shelter for $8 an hour. When von Ehlinger eventually asked her out to dinner, Jane says she initially felt reluctant, but talked about it with her friends, who told her to go for the food. Remember, she was 19 -- only a year out of high school. He was 38.
有时，这些免费食物确实不错。简的实习是没有工资的。她靠一份兼职工作抚养自己和三岁的儿子。她在一家家庭暴力收容所上夜班，每小时8美元。当冯·埃林格最终约她出去吃饭时，“简”说她起初感到勉强，但和朋友们聊了聊，她们告诉她为了食物去吧。记住，她当时才19岁——高中刚毕业一年。他38岁。
Did you think of it as like, this is a date? This is a working dinner? This is something in between or who knows?
你当时觉得这是一次约会吗？这是一次工作晚餐？或者是介于两者之间？
I obviously knew that he was interested in me, but I more or less was like, well, he's going to help me out. Like, because I told him all my interests, right? Like, I was like, I want to work on the judiciary system, blah, blah, blah, and he's like, you know, I know these people and I could maybe, you know, connect you with, like, he was, no, he didn't, like, promise anything, but he definitely was like, hey, I could help you out. And that was my goal.
我显然知道他对我有兴趣，但我更多的是觉得，好吧，他会帮我一把。因为我告诉了他我所有的兴趣，对吧？我当时说，我想研究司法系统，巴拉巴拉，他说，你知道，我认识这些人，我也许可以，你知道，把你介绍给——不，他没有承诺什么，但他确实说，嘿，我可以帮你。那就是我的目标。
She wanted to grow her network. Von Ehlinger picked Jane up after she'd finished her internship for the day in a BMW he borrowed from his roommate, then drove her to a steak restaurant downtown.
她想扩展自己的人脉。冯·埃林格在“简”结束当天实习工作后，开着他从室友那里借来的宝马车接了她，然后带她去了市中心的一家牛排馆。
And then over dinner, he had made some weird remarks, and I was like, this is kind of weird.
然后在晚餐时，他说了一些奇怪的言论，我心想，这有点奇怪。
What kind of remarks struck you as weird?
什么言论让你觉得奇怪？
Because he was like, I have a dry sense of humor. Like, what are you doing later? And I'm like, I'm going to go pick up my son, I guess. Like, I don't know. Like I'm just going to go home. And he's like, oh, well I'm hoping to do you. And he was just laughing, and then he just, like, ate, and then the waiter guy came up and I was like, OK. I just wanted to ignore it. Like the other things, I'm just like, oh, just pretend I didn't hear that. Because not to egg it on -- I definitely wasn't trying to make it worse. And then we were going to leave and I was like, cool, I'm going to go home.
因为他说，我很有冷幽默感。比如，你之后打算做什么？我说，我要去接我儿子，我想。就像，我不知道。我只是要回家。他说，噢，我希望能“做了你”（do you）。他当时还在笑，然后就继续吃东西，服务员走过来，我心想，好吧。我只是想忽略它。就像其他事情一样，我心想，噢，假装我没听到。因为不是为了刺激他——我绝对没有想要让情况变糟。然后我们准备离开，我说，酷，我要回家了。
Von Ehlinger was supposed to take her straight back to her car at the capitol, but instead, he made a detour to his apartment, supposedly to run a quick errand. This is probably evident, but a heads up that this is where the rape happens, and I'm going to give some of those details. Jane gave me permission and felt it was important to lay out the specifics of what happened to her. After he parked, Jane felt pressured to go in. She says he opened her car door and reached for her arm. She felt anxious knowing that he sometimes carried a handgun. Once inside his apartment, Jane tried to keep some distance. She went and sat on his couch, but he picked her up and carried her to his bedroom.
冯·埃林格本应直接把她带回议会大厦的车上，但他却绕道去了他的公寓，说是去办个小差事。这很明显，但我还是要预警，强奸就是在这里发生的，我要讲一些细节。“简”给了我许可，并觉得列出所发生事情的细节很重要。停好车后，“简”感到被逼着进去。她说他打开了车门，抓住了她的手臂。她感到焦虑，因为知道他随身带着手枪。进入公寓后，“简”试图保持距离。她走到他的沙发上坐下，但他抱起她，把她带进了卧室。
I wanted to run out of his -- like I was envisioning myself running out of his room and, like, running down the hall, but it was just in my head. Like I couldn't do it. I don't know. Like my brain was shot, like I couldn't move. You know, when you're paralyzed like, I can't move.
我本想跑出他的房间——我在脑海里幻想着自己跑出他的房间，沿着走廊跑，但那只是在我的脑海里。我做不到。我不知道。就像我的大脑死机了，我无法移动。你知道，当你瘫痪时，我无法移动。
Jane kept saying no, but von Ehlinger forced his penis into her mouth. She pulled her head away so hard that it snapped back and hit the wall. He then climbed on top of her, pinning one of her arms under his knee, masturbating. Von Ehlinger was over 6 feet, 200 pounds. Jane's 5' 3".
“简”一直在说不，但冯·埃林格强行将他的生殖器塞进她嘴里。她用力甩开自己的头，头撞到了墙上。然后他骑在她身上，用膝盖压住她的一条手臂，开始自慰。冯·埃林格身高超过6英尺，体重200磅。“简”身高5英尺3英寸。
I just stared at his curtains. They were so dark, like I called them American red in my head, is what I was naming them. Like I was in disbelief. Like I said no. I said no. What was I supposed to do? Hit him? Was I supposed to attack him? Like, he should have just gotten off of me, and he didn't. He just didn't, and I was so shocked.
我只是盯着他的窗帘。它们太深了，我在脑海里叫它们“美国红”，这是我起的名字。就像我简直不敢相信。我说了不。我说了不。我该怎么办？打他？我该攻击他吗？就像，他本应该从我身上下去的，但他没下去。他就是没下去，我太震惊了。
Afterward, she says, he told her, when I'm at this point, I just become an out of control man. He then acted like nothing happened and drove her back to her car.
事后，她说，他告诉她，“当我到这一步时，我就成了失控的男人。”然后他像什么都没发生一样，把她送回了她的车。
Jane Doe had been assaulted by a state legislator. Now she had to try to figure out what to do next. Like the vast majority of sexual assault survivors, Jane decided she wasn't going to tell anyone. She wanted to get back to work. She tried to convince herself she was fine, but that plan fell apart when she showed up back at the capitol for work just a couple of days later.
“简·多伊”遭到了一位州议员的袭击。现在她得设法弄清楚下一步该怎么做。像绝大多数性侵受害者一样，简决定谁也不告诉。她想回去工作。她试图说服自己她很好，但当几天后她回到议会大厦上班时，这个计划破灭了。
And so I was on the ground floor going towards where my office is, and I seen him at the very end, like, walking out of a committee room, and I was like, I can't do this. I can't, I can't do this.
所以我在一楼正往我的办公室方向走，看见他就在走廊尽头，从委员会会议室走出来，我当时想，我做不到。我无法面对他。
When you saw him, did he see you?
当你看到他时，他看到你了吗？
No. I was like, oh my gosh. I just had to hold on to the wall. I was like-
没有。我心想，天哪。我只能扶着墙。我当时——
[EXHALES]
[呼气声]
Like, you know, right in the middle of a frigging panic attack. I was, like, not functioning. I couldn't function. I was scared. I was so scared, like I went straight to Kim Blackburn.
就像，你知道，正处在惊恐发作中。我当时完全无法正常工作。我无法正常运作。我很害怕。我太害怕了，我直接去了金·布莱克本（Kim Blackburn）那里。
Kim Blackburn. That's who she talked to -- the assistant sergeant at arms for the House. When Jane was a high school page the previous year, Kim was her supervisor. It was hard to find a private place to talk, so they walked out to the rotunda and sat on a bench facing that big Idaho state flag. Jane told Kim that von Ehlinger had raped her, then she went to the bathroom and threw up.
金·布莱克本。就是她谈话的对象——众议院助理军士长。“简”前一年做高中传令员时，金就是她的主管。很难找到私下交谈的地方，所以他们走到圆形大厅，坐在面对那面巨大的爱达荷州州旗的长椅上。简告诉金冯·埃林格强奸了她，然后她去洗手间吐了。
Well initially, to even report, I was like -- to convince myself, I was like, well, I'm a citizen. I'm a constituent. I witnessed a crime brought by one of their legislators and I am giving that to the higher up or whatever, you know what I mean? I'm reporting that because that's what a good Samaritan does. That's what you do. That's what you're supposed to do, and so me being a domestic violence, sexual assault advocate myself, what would I be telling a different 19 year old who got assaulted by a legislator? So I was like, cool. Not cool, but like, cool. Like I will do this.
嗯最初，为了举报，我当时是——为了说服自己，我说，好吧，我是一个公民。我是选民。我目睹了他们的议员之一犯下的罪行，我要把这个举报给上面的人，你明白我的意思吗？我举报是因为那是好撒玛利亚人会做的。那是你应该做的。那是你该做的，所以我自己作为一个家庭暴力、性侵犯倡导者，如果那是另一个被议员侵犯的19岁女孩，我会告诉她什么？所以我心想，酷。其实不酷，但我的意思是，好吧。我会这么做的。
Like I don't really want to do this, but I have to do this?
就像你其实并不想做，但你不得不做？
Oh yeah. Why would you want to do that? Why would anybody want to do that? Why would anybody choose to be like, yeah, take my life, right? My whole life. So at that point, I was like, fuck it. This is my job now.
哦，是的。为什么你会想做那种事？为什么会有人想做那种事？为什么会有人选择说，好的，拿走我的生活吧，对吗？我的一生。所以在那一点上，我心想，去他的。这就是我现在的任务了。
This is where things started going differently than they would have in years past at the Idaho Capitol. Jane didn't know this, but when she told the supervisor about von Ehlinger, she became the first person to publicly test out the legislature's brand new process for responding to sexual misconduct allegations. The assistant sergeant at arms was now required to share Jane's report with one of the higher ups.
这就是情况开始与爱达荷州国会大厦往年不同的地方。简不知道这一点，但当她向主管讲述冯·埃林格的事情时，她成了第一个公开测试议会针对性行为不端指控的全新流程的人。助理军士长现在被要求将“简”的报告分享给高层之一。
She went to the top person in the House, the Speaker, who took it very seriously. Within minutes of receiving Jane's report, he notified the Attorney General's office, who then notified the Boise Police. They took her to a victim center, where a nurse gave her a rape kit exam. But Jane waffled about whether she wanted to move forward with a police investigation and decided she didn't want to press charges. She wanted to move on, focus on her work, and let the capitol deal with von Ehlinger so another intern didn't get hurt.
她去了众议院最高负责人——议长那里，议长非常认真地对待了这件事。在收到“简”的报告几分钟内，他通知了总检察长办公室，然后又通知了博伊西警方。他们带她去了受害者中心，护士为她做了强奸取证。但关于是否要推动警察调查，“简”犹豫不决，最终决定不提出指控。她想继续前进，专注于工作，让国会大厦处理冯·埃林格的问题，以免另一个实习生受到伤害。
The new protocol at the capitol landed with the Ethics Committee in the Idaho House, but then what? While the legislature had a way to respond to sexual misconduct complaints, it did not have any guidelines for how to conduct this kind of investigation. Representative Sage Dixon, a Republican from Northern Idaho, chaired the Ethics Committee. He was the first one on it to see Jane's report.
国会大厦的新协议交给了爱达荷州众议院的道德委员会，但后来呢？虽然立法机构有一种响应性行为不端投诉的方法，但却没有关于如何进行此类调查的准则。北爱达荷州的共和党议员赛奇·迪克森（Sage Dixon）担任道德委员会主席。他是委员会中第一个看到“简”报告的人。
It shocked me because I wasn't aware of any of that, so it was a lot to absorb. I was disturbed in thinking that this is quite possibly going to be something larger than we'd like it to be, as far as within Idaho.
这让我很震惊，因为我对这些一无所知，所以很难消化。我很不安，心想这很可能比我们希望看到的规模更大，就爱达荷州内部而言。
Had you ever handled anything like this as a legislator?
你作为立法者处理过这类事情吗？
No.
没有。
Most everything that happened next, Dixon and his committee had to make up. He had no training on how to run an investigation into a sexual misconduct complaint. His job outside of the House is running an electrical contracting business. So one of his first thoughts was we should talk to Jane. Jane was at the capitol when a secretary notified her to appear before the House Ethics Committee. She didn't know what to expect, so when she headed into that interview, she brought a lawyer who's also a sexual assault advocate.
接下来发生的大部分事情，迪克森和他的委员会不得不现编。他没有接受过任何关于如何调查性行为不端投诉的培训。他在众议院之外的工作是经营一家电气承包企业。所以他的第一个想法是我们应该和“简”谈谈。当秘书通知“简”前往众议院道德委员会面前时，她正在国会大厦。她不知道会发生什么，所以当她进入面试时，她带了一位也是性侵犯倡导者的律师。
And right before we walked in there, all we heard from that room -- a burst of laughter, and so that already made me, like, what the heck? Did you hear that? Me and my lawyer were like, are they laughing right now? What are they laughing about?
就在我们走进去之前，我们听到房间里传出一阵笑声，那已经让我，就像，到底怎么回事？你听到了吗？我和我的律师都在想，他们现在在笑吗？他们在笑什么？
How did that make you feel, walking into that room?
那让你感觉如何，走进那个房间？
I was more irritated. More like confused, kind of hurt -- kind of felt judged.
我更生气。更像是困惑，有点受伤——感觉受到了评判。
Dixon says he doesn't remember what they were talking about, but was certain they weren't laughing about Jane. Once Jane walked in the room, she saw the Ethics Committee was made up of Representatives she saw all the time at her internship. She felt ashamed. They were seated around a long table -- three men and two women. She took a seat at the end. Dixon asked her to recount the night von Ehlinger raped her, but as soon as she got to the part about him climbing on top of her, Dixon stopped her. He said, quote, "I think maybe the committee's getting uncomfortable, too."
迪克森说他不记得他们在谈论什么，但确定他们不是在笑“简”。当“简”走进房间时，她看到道德委员会是由她实习期间经常见到的议员组成的。她感到羞耻。他们围坐在长桌旁——三名男性和两名女性。她在末端找了个位子坐下。迪克森要求她重述冯·埃林格强奸她的那一晚，但当她讲到他骑在她身上的那一刻，迪克森打断了她。他说，引用：“我想也许委员会也感到不舒服了。”
At first, I was just like, what did you say? Well I didn't say that, but I was like, you are telling me that I'm making you uncomfortable? Like you're telling me -- you're telling me. I was assaulted sexually, but you're uncomfortable with this conversation after you asked me to have this conversation. You asked me. You brought me here. You made this happen, and you're just going to tell me to stop. What? Like this doesn't, it made me so angry.
起初，我只是想，你说什么？好吧，我没说出口，但我是想说，你是说我让你感到不舒服了？你是说——你在跟我说。我被性侵了，但在你要求我进行这段对话后，你却对这段对话感到不舒服。是你要求的。是你带我来这里的。是你促成这一切的，然后你竟然叫我停下。什么？就像这简直——这让我太生气了。
I read the transcript of this, and later he said, please don't think that we're, I'm cutting you off because we don't want to hear anything more. And so, did that clarification make a difference to you?
我读过这段记录，后来他说，请不要认为我们，我打断你是为了不想听更多。所以，那个澄清对你有影响吗？
No. Not in any way. Like, that was a huge insult. You made me relive a horrible experience and just tell me you're uncomfortable by it. I was so hurt. I was so hurt by Dixon because I know his son. I'm friends with his son. He was a page with me. Dang. You hurt me, Dixon. You hurt me. You hurt me.
没有。一点也没有。那简直是巨大的侮辱。你让我重温了可怕的经历，然后只是告诉我你感到不舒服。我太受伤了。我被迪克森深深地伤害了，因为我认识他的儿子。我和他的儿子是朋友。那是和我一起做传令员的。天呐。你伤害了我，迪克森。你伤害了我。你伤害了我。
There are some well-established practices for interviewing sexual assault victims. Using trained investigators who know how to interview a victim without re-traumatizing them is one, and those investigators should be external and independent, not people who work together every day. I asked Dixon about that moment in the room. He told me after Jane left, a Deputy AG who was there told him you don't interrupt sexual assault victims in the middle of their story.
有一些公认的采访性侵受害者的做法。聘请受过培训、知道如何在不造成二次创伤的情况下采访受害者的调查员就是其中之一，而且这些调查员应该是外部的、独立的，而不是每天都在一起工作的同事。我问迪克森关于房间里那一刻的事情。他告诉我，“简”离开后，在场的一位副总检察长告诉他：你不能在性侵受害者讲述故事的过程中打断她。
I could tell Jane Doe was getting visibly disturbed and I didn't want her to be that way, so I told her you don't need to answer any more. Just dead stop. We're done. We're fine, trying to protect her the best way as a husband and a father that I would think to protect somebody that's vulnerable and having a hard time. Not knowing that dynamic -- now I know that it was hard at that point, that it was one of the difficult things. So I apologize to her about that. I'm sure that made it tougher.
我能看出“简·多伊”明显变得不安，我不想让她那样，所以我告诉她你不需要再回答了。就此打住。我们完了。我们很好，试图以一个丈夫和一个父亲保护弱势且处境艰难的人的方式来保护她。当时不知道那种动态——现在我知道在那一点上很困难，那是一件困难的事情。所以我为此向她道歉。我肯定那让事情变得更艰难了。
The Ethics Committee doesn't investigate crimes. They had no protocol for what to do, but they did have this one thing -- something that was clearly in the purview of the Ethics Committee -- conduct unbecoming. Was Representative von Ehlinger's conduct conduct unbecoming? As they looked into it, reports started surfacing about other women he'd pursued and made uncomfortable in his very short time at the capitol -- a journal clerk, a security guard, and a lobbyist who said he followed her to the bathroom. All of them were younger than him.
道德委员会不调查刑事犯罪。他们没有任何协议该做什么，但他们确实有这一条——清楚地在道德委员会权限范围内的事情——行为不当（conduct unbecoming）。冯·埃林格议员的行为是行为不当吗？在他们调查的过程中，关于他在短暂的国会任期内追求并让其他女性感到不舒服的报告开始浮出水面——一名书记员、一名保安，还有一名说他跟着她去了洗手间的游说者。她们都比他年轻。
The committee also discovered that the top leadership in the House knew about two of these reports. Instead of confronting von Ehlinger, they sent a representative to warn him to stop being, quote, "overly nice." Dixon and the committee brought these allegations to him and gave von Ehlinger the chance to resign quietly and to avoid any public embarrassment.
委员会还发现，众议院的高层领导知道其中两份报告。他们没有去对质冯·埃林格，而是派了一位议员去警告他停止“过于友善”。迪克森和委员会将这些指控带给他，给了冯·埃林格一个安静辞职的机会，以避免任何公开的尴尬。
But he didn't step down. Instead, he told the committee he and Jane Doe had consensual sex. To them, pursuing a sexual relationship of any kind with an intern was not OK. It seemed like a clear violation of the rule -- conduct unbecoming. Since he refused to resign, the only option they had left was to convince two-thirds of the House that von Ehlinger had violated conduct unbecoming. Then they could get him expelled. But to do this, they'd have to hold a public hearing.
但他没有下台。相反，他告诉委员会他和“简·多伊”发生了两厢情愿的性关系。对他们来说，追求任何类型的实习生性关系都是不可接受的。这似乎明显违反了规则——行为不当。既然他拒绝辞职，他们剩下的唯一选择就是说服三分之二的众议院相信冯·埃林格的行为属于行为不当。然后他们才能驱逐他。但要做到这一点，他们必须举行公开听证会。
Once the hearing was announced, one of von Ehlinger's attorneys did something that shocked Jane and her lawyers -- he released Jane's name to reporters. It ended up on a far right news site with her photo. Jane was no longer anonymous.
听证会宣布后，冯·埃林格的一位律师做了一件震惊“简”及其律师的事——他向记者公布了“简”的名字。它最终出现在一个极右翼新闻网站上，并附上了她的照片。简不再匿名了。
I'm just like, holy shit, my world is ending. Nobody would talk to me. Nobody would even look at me in the eye anymore. I went from smiling and waving to everybody to nobody would look at me. And so then that's when I was really like, dang, they hate me. Like everybody in that state house just hates me.
我只是觉得，天呐，我的世界要结束了。没人愿意跟我说话。甚至没人愿意再看着我的眼睛。我从微笑着向大家挥手变成了没人愿意看着我。所以我那时真的觉得，该死，他们恨我。就像国会大厦里的每一个人都恨我。
An ally of von Ehlinger in the House went after Jane, too -- a then representative named Priscilla Giddings. She posted Jane's photo on Facebook and emailed a newsletter to her constituents calling von Ehlinger Idaho's very own Kavanaugh and Jane a honey trap out on a liberal smear job. The hearing, she said, was part of a national #MeToo witch hunt. I reached out to Giddings, but she didn't respond.
冯·埃林格在众议院的一个盟友也针对了“简”——时任议员普里西拉·吉丁斯（Priscilla Giddings）。她在Facebook上发布了“简”的照片，并向选民发送了一封通讯，称冯·埃林格是爱达荷州自己的卡瓦诺，而“简”是一个自由派抹黑行动中的“美人计”。她说，听证会是全国性“我也是”女巫狩猎行动的一部分。我联系了吉丁斯，但她没有回应。
Jane tried to keep going to work, but she hated that every time someone looked at her, they thought about the rape. She couldn't function and needed to get out of the capitol. Back at home, all she could do to get through the day was sleep. She couldn't keep food down and was failing all of her college classes except for one -- a criminal justice course.
“简”试图继续工作，但她恨透了每次有人看着她，他们想到的都是那场强奸。她无法正常工作，需要离开国会大厦。回到家里，她能度过一天的唯一办法就是睡觉。她吃不下东西，所有的大学课程都挂了，只有一门除外——一门刑事司法课程。
It was victimology.
那是受害者学。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm not even kidding. I'm not even kidding. It was victimology. I was taking victimology all through that.
我不是在开玩笑。我真没开玩笑。那是受害者学。我在经历这一切的同时正在修受害者学。
In victimology, one of the things they talk about is how victims are often re-traumatized by the very systems that are supposed to get them justice. If you're a victim of sexual violence, the trauma is about having no power, so any attempt toward justice -- police, court, or HR procedures -- should be designed to make sure the person feels a sense of control. For instance, before a victim even makes a report, they should know what all the possible steps of the process could be. That way, they can decide if they still want to proceed. And if it's a workplace like the state house, you want to give the victim the option to give their testimony in private instead of forcing them to retell and relive their assault in public.
在受害者学中，他们谈论的一件事是受害者如何被原本应该为他们伸张正义的制度所“二次创伤”。如果你是性暴力的受害者，创伤在于失去权力，所以任何寻求正义的尝试——警察、法院或人事程序——都应该旨在确保当事人感到有掌控感。例如，在受害者举报之前，她应该知道整个过程中所有可能的步骤。这样，她们才能决定是否还要继续。如果是像国会大厦这样的工作场所，你希望给受害者提供私下作证的选择，而不是强迫她们在公开场合重述和重温她们的攻击经历。
In the Idaho House, the process wasn't designed with the sexual assault victim in mind. Instead, it looked a lot more like a regular criminal trial. Dixon talked a lot about von Ehlinger's right to defend himself, while Jane says she wasn't consulted about whether she even wanted to come to the hearing. They issued a subpoena for her to appear. I asked Dixon why he thought that was necessary.
在爱达荷州众议院，这个过程在设计时并没有考虑到性侵受害者。相反，它看起来更像是一场普通的刑事审判。迪克森谈了很多关于冯·埃林格为自己辩护的权利，而“简”则说没人问过她是否愿意来到听证会。他们发出了传票要她出席。我问迪克森为什么认为这有必要。
We were subpoenaing other witnesses, and so to maintain that consistency, I think, is why, and just that it didn't look like we were favoring one side or the other.
我们正在传唤其他证人，所以为了保持这种一致性，我想这就是原因，而且这样看起来我们没有偏袒任何一方。
Because it is a subpoena, if she hadn't appeared, then arrest is the consequence of that, right?
因为这是传票，如果她没有出现，那么后果就是被捕，对吧？
Yes. I don't think it's absolute that arrest is a consequence of that. If we wanted to take it to that end, we could have.
是的。我不认为被捕是必然后果。如果我们想采取那种手段，我们是可以的。
So if she hadn't come, I mean, what would have --
所以如果她没来，我的意思是，会发生什么——
I don't know, Miki. That's tough because I feel she needed to be there for the face-your-accuser portion of it.
我不知道，美纪。那很难，因为我觉得对于“面对你的原告”这一部分，她需要出现在那里。
In the days leading up to the hearing, Jane's lawyer said they did everything they could to prevent the hearing from being a disaster for her. They asked if she could testify remotely and with her voice disguised, or even better, in a closed session that wasn't open to the public. They said the answer they always got back from the Attorney General's office was no. No one seems to have a clear answer on why this was.
在听证会前的几天里，“简”的律师说他们竭尽所能防止听证会成为她的灾难。他们询问她是否可以远程作证并掩盖声音，或者更好的是，在不对公众开放的闭门会议中作证。他们说，从总检察长办公室得到的回复总是“不”。没有人能给出明确的答案为什么。
One of the Deputy AG's running the case declined to comment. Dixon told me he never received her attorney's requests and says he would have been open to Jane testifying remotely. In the end, Jane's lawyer said the only protection that was offered up to her were those black curtains. She would tell her story in public, behind a black curtain.
负责此案的一位副总检察长拒绝置评。迪克森告诉我，他从未收到她律师的请求，并说他会支持“简”远程作证。最终，“简”的律师说提供给她的唯一保护措施就是那些黑布帘。她将在公开场合，在黑布帘后面讲述她的故事。
Miki Meek. Coming up -- the hearing and the protective power of tennis shoes. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
美纪·米克。稍后——听证会以及网球鞋的保护力量。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目将在稍后继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program -- Jane Doe. Five years since #MeToo blew up and there are all these systems that are supposed to crank into action now when somebody steps forward, we have the story of Jane Doe, a teenager in Idaho.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——简·多伊。“我也是”运动爆发五年了，现在有各种系统，当有人站出来时，这些系统就应该启动，我们有“简·多伊”的故事，一位在爱达荷州的青少年。
Now to be clear, Jane Doe did not come forward because of #MeToo. Actually, when our producer, Miki Meek, asked her about it, Jane said all she knew about #MeToo is that it was something for celebrities. Nonetheless, the response to her was shaped by #MeToo. She was a test case of the legislature's new reporting system that they were making up as they went. We pick up our story with Act Two, The Witness. Heads up, this part of the story contains brief references to suicide. Here's Miki.
现在需要说明的是，“简·多伊”并不是因为“我也是”运动才站出来的。事实上，当我们的制片人美纪·米克问起时，“简”说她对“我也是”运动的了解仅限于那是一些名人的事情。尽管如此，对她的反应确实受到了“我也是”运动的影响。她是议会新举报系统的测试案例，他们边做边改。我们进入第二幕，证人。预警：这部分故事包含关于自杀的简要提及。请听美纪的报道。
The morning of the hearing, Jane woke up terrified. She had a full blown panic attack and threw up. She jumped in the shower and put on "Beautiful" by Eminem to try and pump herself up. She then put on a black dress. This was an inside joke to herself because she felt like she was about to attend her own funeral. Jane's mom picked her up and they headed to the capitol.
听证会那天早上，简在恐惧中醒来。她惊恐发作，吐了。她跳进淋浴间，放了阿姆的《Beautiful》来给自己打气。然后她穿上一件黑色连衣裙。这是她给自己开的一个内部玩笑，因为她觉得她快要参加自己的葬礼了。简的妈妈接上她，他们前往国会大厦。
Her lawyers told me that nobody came up with a secure plan to get her into the building without people seeing who she was. So one of her lawyers reached out to a senator who met Jane and her mom at a private entrance outside the capitol, then led them through a series of tunnels and some back hallways until Jane finally got to a door in the hearing room. She looked at the curtains and a random bronze statue of Abraham Lincoln's head. Her chair was right in front of him.
她的律师告诉我，没人制定一个安全的计划把她带进大楼而不被别人看到她的身份。所以她的一位律师联系了一位参议员，他在国会大厦外的私人入口与“简”和她妈妈见面，然后引导他们穿过一系列隧道和后走廊，直到“简”终于到达了听证室的一扇门前。她看着帘子和一尊随机的亚伯拉罕·林肯头部铜像。她的椅子就在他面前。
His eyes wouldn't move, you know? He was just staring at me the whole time, and I was like, OK. It was just weird. It was just flat out weird.
他的眼睛不会动，你知道吗？他一直在盯着我，我心想，好吧。这简直太诡异了。简直怪透了。
What did you think when you saw that black curtain?
当你看到那块黑布帘时，你觉得怎样？
Well, I was like, I can see through this. I can see everybody. Like, they can see me, and I was kind of freaking out at first, but they really couldn't see me.
嗯，我心想，我能看穿这个。我能看到所有人。就像，他们能看到我，我起初有点崩溃，但他们实际上看不到我。
From her side, the curtain looked more sheer. She looked through it to a room packed with legislators and press. The people who could actually see her, though, included five Ethics Committee members, their counsel, a secretary, two Deputy AG's, von Ehlinger's attorney, and von Ehlinger. Jane had only seen him around the capitol a couple of times since he raped her. Her black curtain was slightly open to give those people line of sight on Jane during the hearing.
从她那边看，帘子看起来更透明。她透过帘子看向一个挤满了议员和媒体的房间。然而，真正能看到她的人包括五名道德委员会成员、他们的律师、一名秘书、两名副总检察长、冯·埃林格的律师和冯·埃林格。自强奸发生后，“简”在国会大厦只偶尔见过他几次。她的黑布帘被稍微拉开，以便在听证会期间让那些人能看到“简”。
My body was not there. I just held so tight to my chair -- just held on to it just so I had something.
我的身体不在这儿。我只是紧紧地抓住我的椅子——紧紧抓住它，只是为了有东西抓着。
And you knew they weren't going to protect your voice going into it?
而且你进入之前就知道他们不会保护你的声音？
No.
不知道。
Jane's voice was live-streamed. The hearing was broadcast online.
“简”的声音被直播了。听证会在网上播放。
I think we need to be able to cross-examine the accuser here.
我认为我们需要能够在这里盘问原告。
That's von Ehlinger's attorney. Publicly cross-examining witnesses of sexual assault is certainly not best practice for this kind of thing. For instance, other state legislatures that have adopted procedures for handling complaints do not allow victims to be cross-examined in public, certainly not by the perpetrators. But again, they had no process for this in Idaho.
那是冯·埃林格的律师。公开盘问性侵受害者绝对不是此类事情的最佳实践。例如，其他采用投诉处理程序的州立法机构不允许受害者在公开场合接受盘问，绝对不允许被施暴者盘问。但同样，爱达荷州对此没有任何流程。
So von Ehlinger's lawyer adopted tactics out of a criminal trial. He predictably turned Jane into the defendant, following the usual playbook that gets used on sexual assault victims. He cast her as mentally unstable and a flirt, which was a thing Jane had felt around the capitol ever since she reported von Ehlinger. That she was being judged and cast, in her words, as a, quote, "gold digging, crazy Mexican pothead." Von Ehlinger's lawyer nitpicked tiny details to insinuate that maybe she was a liar.
所以冯·埃林格的律师采取了刑事审判的策略。他不出所料地把“简”变成了被告，遵循了通常用来对付性侵受害者的剧本。他把她描绘成精神不稳定和爱调情的人，这是“简”自从举报冯·埃林格以来在国会大厦一直能感觉到的东西。她正在受到评判，正如她所说的，被定型为“贪财、疯狂的墨西哥瘾君子”。冯·埃林格的律师吹毛求疵，挑剔微小的细节来暗示她可能是个骗子。
I'm just wondering if you can just read that -- just that one sentence.
我只是想问你能不能读一下——就那一个句子。
On the night of March 10, 2021, she met him in downtown Boise.
2021年3月10日晚，她在博伊西市中心见到了他。
Thank you. But it wasn't March 10, 2021, was it?
谢谢。但不是2021年3月10日，对吧？
No.
不是。
It was March 9th. Isn't that correct?
是3月9日。没错吧？
Yes, I told police that.
是的，我告诉警察了。
OK, why did you tell Miss Blackburn that it was March 10?
好吧，你为什么告诉布莱克本小姐那是3月10日？
I didn't. I said the other night.
我没说。我说的是那天晚上。
The supervisor who Jane had reported to is the one who accidentally made a mistake in her written report, not Jane. Meanwhile, von Ehlinger barely spoke. He kept pleading the fifth. When the Ethics Committee kept pointing out that this wasn't a criminal proceeding and it didn't apply, he still refused. What sucked up most of the time, though, was the core of von Ehlinger's defense, which was essentially, this was not rape -- we were dating, which is allowed. There's no anti-fraternization policy in the Idaho state house. Again, here's his attorney.
“简”向其举报的主管才是那个在书面报告中意外犯错的人，而不是“简”。同时，冯·埃林格几乎没怎么说话。他一直保持沉默。当道德委员会一再指出这不是刑事诉讼，且不需要那样做时，他仍然拒绝。然而，耗费大部分时间的是冯·埃林格辩护的核心，本质上就是：这不是强奸——我们在约会，这是允许的。爱达荷州议会没有反办公室恋情政策。再次，请听他律师的话。
Does Representative von Ehlinger have any hiring or firing authority over you?
冯·埃林格议员对你有任何聘用或解雇的权力吗？
No.
没有。
Does Representative von Ehlinger have any supervisory authority over you?
冯·埃林格议员对你有任何监督权力吗？
No.
没有。
OK.
好的。
He asked some version of this question more than 30 times to different witnesses.
他向不同的证人问了这个问题不下30遍。
Are you aware of any policy that would be violated by a representative having a relationship with an intern of the age of majority?
你知道有任何政策禁止议员与成年实习生发生关系吗？
I've seen nothing in policy, no.
我没在政策中看到任何东西，没有。
Thank you.
谢谢。
He's basically saying, tell me where it says a powerful, middle aged legislator can't date a 19-year-old intern, and always got the same answer.
他基本上是在说，告诉我哪儿写着一个有权势的中年议员不能和一个19岁的实习生约会，得到的总是同样的回答。
Written policy, no.
书面政策，没有。
Not that I'm, not that I'm aware of.
据我所知没有。
Absolutely not.
绝对没有。
OK.
好的。
Von Ehlinger's lawyer did the same kind of thing with the other woman who testified about von Ehlinger's troubling behavior. Like a chief clerk who said one of her employees complained when von Ehlinger asked her out. His attorney's response to that was, she wasn't wearing a wedding ring, which of course, has nothing to do with whether von Ehlinger should have asked her out at work. His attorney charged ahead.
冯·埃林格的律师对另一位作证关于冯·埃林格令人不安行为的女性也做了同样的事情。比如一位首席书记员，她说当冯·埃林格约她出去时，她的一名员工提出了投诉。他律师的回答是，她当时没戴结婚戒指，这当然与冯·埃林格是否应该在工作中约她出去毫无关系。他的律师冲在前面。
Ms. Maulin, in your experience, isn't wearing a wedding ring a generally accepted sign that a woman is unavailable?
多林小姐，根据你的经验，没戴结婚戒指不是一个被普遍接受的女性处于单身状态的标志吗？
It can be construed that way, but I don't think that that's a requirement to be unavailable.
它可以这样理解，但我不认为那是衡量是否单身的必要条件。
I didn't ask if it was a requirement. Is it completely unreasonable, in your opinion, for an individual who is interested in a woman to notice that she is not wearing a wedding ring and assume he's permitted to ask her a question?
我没问那是否是必要条件。在你看来，一个对女性感兴趣的人注意到她没戴结婚戒指并假设他可以问她一个问题，这是完全不合理的吗？
I don't think a wedding ring is indicative of whether or not you can ask a woman a question.
我不认为结婚戒指能说明你能否问一个女性问题。
This is an absurd thing to argue, but he's also arguing inside an absurd, incoherent set of rules. The Idaho legislature has a process for reporting sexual harassment, but not actually a policy against it in the rules for the Senate and the House. They don't have an anti-fraternization policy, but they have rules about decorum -- rules forbidding smoking, drinking, and eating on the House floor. A rule about conduct unbecoming of a state legislator, but nothing for sexual harassment.
这是一种荒谬的辩论，但他也是在荒谬、不连贯的规则体系内进行辩论。爱达荷州立法机构有举报性骚扰的程序，但在参议院和众议院的规则中实际上没有禁止性骚扰的政策。他们没有反办公室恋情政策，但有关于礼仪的规则——禁止在众议院议事厅吸烟、饮酒和进食的规则。有一条关于州议员行为不端的规则，但没有关于性骚扰的规则。
The part of the hearing I'd always wanted to know more about ever since I first saw it was what happened when Jane finally walked away from that black curtain. She sat behind it for 40 minutes, answering questions.
从我第一次看到那场听证会起，我就一直想了解更多细节，那就是“简”终于从那个黑布帘走开时发生了什么。她在后面坐了40分钟，回答问题。
Thank you, Ms. Doe, you are excused.
谢谢你，多伊小姐，你可以退席了。
I freaking lose it. I lose it. And then I was just angry. I was like, I'm going to get the F out of here. I don't want to be here anymore. You think I want to help you?
我简直要疯了。我要崩溃了。然后我只是生气。我心想，我要滚出这里。我不想再待在这儿了。你以为我想帮你？
Jane told me that when she stood up to leave, she had a panic attack. There was a private exit she was supposed to go out of, but she was so upset that she pushed through the wrong door and landed out in a public hallway. That's when that scream came out of her.
“简”告诉我，当她站起来离开时，她惊恐发作了。本来有一个私人出口她应该从那儿出去，但她太难过了，推开了错误的门，最终走到了一条公共走廊里。那就是那声尖叫出来的时候。
[SCREAM]
[尖叫声]
Just start running up the hallway, and that's when I heard people behind me.
开始沿着走廊跑，那是我就听到身后有人。
Some of von Ehlinger's supporters -- all women -- followed her out into the hallway. There was a local reporter with them, too. They crowded around her and started filming Jane with their phones.
冯·埃林格的一些支持者——都是女性——跟着她进入了走廊。还有一个当地记者也跟着。他们围住她，开始用手机拍摄“简”。
I broke. I broke. I screamed. I screamed a lot. Like screaming how much I was going to kill myself. All I wanted to do was get to the top of the building.
我崩溃了。我崩溃了。我尖叫。我尖叫了很多次。就像尖叫着说我要自杀。我只想跑到大楼的最高处。
She was trying to get to a balcony in the rotunda to throw herself off. Her lawyers blocked her. Jane collapsed on the ground. Her mom held her while her lawyers pulled out an umbrella and opened it to try and block her face from the people filming her. It took several minutes before security at the capitol finally showed up and escorted Jane out of the building.
她正试图跑到圆形大厅的阳台跳下去。她的律师拦住了她。简瘫倒在地上。她的妈妈抱着她，律师撑开一把伞，试图挡住她的脸不让拍摄的人看到。过了几分钟，国会大厦的安保人员终于赶到，把“简”护送出了大楼。
The hearing lasted two days. At the end of the second day, the committee recommended to expel him. He resigned just hours later. Representative Dixon, head of the Ethics Committee, saw this as a successful outcome. I told Dixon how traumatizing the whole experience was for Jane, and what happened after she ran out of the hearing room.
听证会持续了两天。第二天结束时，委员会建议驱逐他。几个小时后他就辞职了。道德委员会负责人迪克森议员认为这是一个成功的结果。我告诉迪克森整个经历对“简”来说有多大的创伤，以及她跑出听证室后发生了什么。
I mean, if that's what the consequences were for her for showing up in public -- for testifying in public, I mean, is it, yeah, was it worth having her be in public like that?
我的意思是，如果那是她公开露面——公开作证的后果，我的意思是，是啊，让她那样公开作证真的值得吗？
Probably not. But again, this was all new to us as a committee. Not being familiar with that trauma and how it expresses itself in people, we had no idea and did everything we thought we were doing correctly to protect her. But I think we could have gone on without that because we did have her previous testimony that we could have brought up and had or showed everybody. We had the transcripts that we were able to show to the body, which again, was important to me so that they knew what we had known. And that probably would have sufficed.
可能不值得。但同样，这对我们委员会来说都是全新的。不熟悉那种创伤以及它如何在人们身上表现出来，我们一点头绪都没有，并尽了我们认为正确的一切努力来保护她。但我认为我们可以不用那样做，因为我们有她之前的证词，我们可以提出来或展示给所有人看。我们有记录，可以展示给整个议会，这对我很重要，让他们知道我们所知道的。这可能就足够了。
This, of course, is impossible to know. Another member of the Ethics Committee told me they thought without Jane's testimony in person, von Ehlinger would still be in the legislature.
这当然无法证实。道德委员会的另一名成员告诉我，他们认为如果没有“简”亲自作证，冯·埃林格依然会留在议会。
I mean, is there anything that you would want her to know or that you...
我的意思是，有什么你希望她知道的，或者你……
Just I'm very sorry if we increased that trauma or that we did, because it never was our intent. I know each one of those members feels very strongly that she was wronged and wanted to protect her, but just due to our inexperience, things didn't come out maybe as cleanly as they could have.
只是我非常抱歉，如果我们加剧了那种创伤，或者我们做了什么，因为那绝不是我们的本意。我知道每一位成员都强烈感受到她受到了冤枉，并想保护她，但由于我们的经验不足，事情可能没有像我们预期的那样处理得那么干净。
So what happened to Jane after all of that? She never finished the internship she loved at the capitol, and after the hearing, never went back to her office with her name in all caps. Five months after the hearing, she was cleaning houses and she was a wreck. She'd lost 20 pounds. She couldn't stop replaying the assault and the hearing in her head. So much of her day-to-day now was a physical battle. She was dealing with severe PTSD.
那么在那之后“简”发生了什么？她再也没有完成她在国会大厦热爱的实习工作，听证会后，再也没回到那间名字全大写的办公室。听证会五个月后，她靠打扫房屋维生，而且整个人彻底垮了。她瘦了20磅。她无法停止在脑海里重温那场袭击和听证会。她现在的日常生活中很大一部分是一场身体的战斗。她患有严重的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。
Just going on the freeway and you would see the tip of the capitol, like my body would just, like [GASP]. Immediately. Just like when you're falling, can you imagine just that [GASP] moment? Like just staying in that. My body is just in a state of shock, you know? Like, frozen.
只要上高速公路，看到国会大厦的顶端，我的身体就像会[喘气]。立即。就像你跌倒时，你能想象那种[喘气]时刻吗？就像停留在那里。我的身体处于休克状态，你懂吗？就像，僵住了。
She was still getting harassed by von Ehlinger sympathizers who continued to publish her name online. Random strangers had shown up at her old apartment, asking questions. There was even a man who'd show up at Boise political events, mocking her, dressed as a woman, wearing a sash with Jane's real name on it. There were also people who sympathized with her, too, and that was also hard. When she was out in public, she never knew when someone was going to try and approach her.
她仍然受到冯·埃林格同情者的骚扰，他们继续在网上发布她的名字。随机的陌生人出现在她以前的公寓，问东问西。甚至有一个男人出现在博伊西的政治活动上，打扮成女人的样子，戴着写有“简”真名的绶带，嘲笑她。也有同情她的人，这也是一种折磨。当她在公共场合时，她从不知道什么时候会有人试图接近她。
Like people are like, are you Jane Doe?
比如人们会问，你是简·多伊吗？
Where does this come up when you get recognized?
当被认出来时，这话题会怎么引出来？
So I went to a job fair, OK, and it was just a bunch of booths of people, and you just go to the next one. And this one lady I went up to went, and I was like, you know, my name is [BLEEP]. I worked here and here, blah, blah, blah. I think I'd be, I'd like to take an application. And she's just like, her eyes were already watering. Like she was already, like, crying, and she's like, miss, did you, are you Jane Doe?
我去了一个招聘会，好吧，那儿有一堆摊位，你只要走到下一个就行。我走到这个女士面前，我说，你知道，我的名字是[消音]。我曾在某某地方工作，巴拉巴拉。我想取一份申请表。然后她只是，她的眼睛已经湿润了。她已经，就像，在哭了，她说，小姐，你是简·多伊吗？
What did you say?
你说了什么？
I was like, fuck. But I was like, yes. Yes, ma'am. Like, yeah. And she's like, oh my gosh. Like, I watched that, blah, blah, blah. And then I was recognized again at the Walmart, and that lady recognized me by my face. You know, and then that's when a lot of people try to share their frickin' rape stories, and you're just like, I really don't want to hear that. Like, I'm still recovering from my own. Like, why would you share that? So not that I don't care, per se, right? But I don't care. I don't want to hear it.
我说，去他的。但我说，是的。是的，女士。就像，是啊。她说，天哪。就像，我看了那个，巴拉巴拉。然后我再次在沃尔玛被认出来，那位女士通过我的脸认出了我。你知道，然后很多人就试图分享他们该死的强奸故事，你只会觉得，我真的不想听那个。就像，我还在从我自己的经历中恢复。就像，你为什么要分享那个？不是说我不关心，对吧？但我就是不关心。我不想听。
Jane started talking about herself in the past tense. I was high energy. I was spunky. I was funny. And her plans felt past tense, too. She no longer talked about being a lawmaker. She was sure she could never set foot back in the capitol, and was thinking about moving out of state. The state house had a process to take her seriously when she reported von Ehlinger, but after that, they had nothing. Jane felt like they weren't concerned with what the experience did to her.
“简”开始用过去时态谈论自己。我精力充沛。我生机勃勃。我很有趣。她的计划也感觉像是过去时了。她不再谈论成为一名立法者。她肯定自己再也不会踏入国会大厦，并考虑搬出州外。州议会有一个流程来认真对待她举报冯·埃林格的行为，但那之后，他们什么都没有。简觉得他们并不关心那种经历对她做了什么。
They just needed my testimony. They needed to do this because they needed to do their jobs. Like they didn't really look at me as a human. They were just, oh, well she reported this, so she got to do this. So might as well just fucking make her, right? Like that's what it felt like, that they only needed me to get this process going. Like they didn't consider anything else. And so I mean, that's where it gets me. Like I mean, what would you do, what would you have done if I was your kid? What would you have made sure happen if I was yours?
他们只是需要我的证词。他们需要这样做是因为他们需要做好自己的工作。就像他们并没有真正把我当人看。他们只是，噢，好吧，她举报了这个，所以她得做这个。所以不如强迫她做，对吧？就像那种感觉，他们只用我来启动这个过程。就像他们没有考虑任何其他事情。所以我就是觉得难以接受。我的意思是，如果我是你的孩子，你会怎么做？如果我是你的孩子，你会确保发生什么？
All Jane had wanted to do was work at the capitol, but after she got doxxed, she said everyone there who talked to her about job opportunities went silent. To make money, she started helping her stepdad out at his plumbing business and picked up work as a caregiver at a memory care facility. And then one year after the ethics hearing, Jane got a rare sort of do over of the entire ordeal with von Ehlinger. The District Attorney in the County for Boise charged him with felony rape.
“简”想要做的只是在国会大厦工作，但被“人肉”后，她说那里所有跟她谈论工作机会的人都沉默了。为了赚钱，她开始帮她继父的水管生意，还找了一份在记忆护理中心做护理员的工作。然后，在道德听证会一年后，“简”获得了一次罕见的关于冯·埃林格折磨她的重审机会。博伊西县地方检察官起诉他犯有重罪强奸。
This happened because after she got doxxed, Jane told the police she'd cooperate with the criminal case. She was so scared all the time, she felt like she had to for her own protection. This time, things went very differently. The prosecutors handling her case understood that they needed to deal with her with care. They walked her through each step so she always knew what to expect. They did not subpoena her. They intentionally built a whole case where she didn't have to take the stand. They had other witnesses like the nurse who did Jane's rape kit exam.
这发生在被“人肉”后，“简”告诉警方她会配合刑事案件。她一直很害怕，觉得为了自己的保护她必须配合。这一次，情况进展非常不同。负责她案件的检察官明白他们需要小心对待她。他们带她完成了每一步，所以她总是知道会发生什么。他们没有传唤她。他们故意构建了一个她无需出庭的完整案例。他们有其他证人，比如为“简”做强奸取证的护士。
But Jane decided that she did want to testify against von Ehlinger. A Sheriff picked her up in an unmarked car and drove her to a secret courthouse entrance. She had a therapy dog named Yuko in the courtroom and a victim witness coordinator by her side. I was there, sitting a couple rows behind von Ehlinger, but even with all that support, watching Jane on the stand that day was harrowing. She looked like she was having an out-of-body experience. She stared at him blankly and could barely talk. When she tried to answer questions about how he'd raped her, she suddenly stopped. She pushed her chair away from the mic, stood up, and said, I can't do this. She walked out of the courtroom.
但“简”决定她还是想指证冯·埃林格。一名治安官开着一辆便车把她送到法庭的秘密入口。她在法庭里有一只名叫Yuko的治疗犬，身边有一名受害者证人协调员。我就在那里，坐在冯·埃林格身后几排，但即使有所有这些支持，那天在证人席上看着“简”也是令人心碎的。她看起来像是灵魂出窍了。她呆滞地盯着他，几乎无法说话。当她试图回答关于他是如何强奸她的问题时，她突然停住了。她把椅子推离麦克风，站起来说，我做不到。她走出了法庭。
So I ran out of the room and immediately fell down a flight of stairs. Like that sounds stupid, but I did, and I don't know what, in my mind, like, I just needed to run, and then I ran across Front Street. I ran across Myrtle, which is the big road. Big, busy roads -- downtown Boise. Four lanes. I was trying to go to the bridge, OK. In my brain, that's where I was going, but my ankle was getting to me.
所以我跑出了房间，立即摔下了一段楼梯。就像这听起来很愚蠢，但我确实摔了，我不知道为什么，在我的脑海里，我只是需要逃跑，然后我跑过了Front街。我跑过了Myrtle，那是条大路。又大又繁忙的马路——博伊西市中心。四车道。我试图去那座桥，好吧。在我的大脑里，那就是我要去的地方，但我的脚踝疼得要命。
The bridge, she says, because maybe she could jump. She was having a post-traumatic reaction. Same as at the hearing, Jane's first instinct was to do what she hadn't been able to do the night she was raped: run away. She'd torn a tendon and leaned up against a tree. One of her attorneys named Guy followed her out to try to calm her. Guy says when the police showed up, one of them grabbed her arm and dropped her to the ground. Jane was so distraught, she doesn't remember that.
她说要去那座桥，因为也许她可以跳下去。她出现了创伤后反应。和听证会时一样，“简”的第一本能是做她在被强奸那天晚上没能做到的事：逃跑。她拉伤了肌腱，靠在一棵树上。她的一位律师盖伊（Guy）跟着她出来试图安抚她。盖伊说当警察出现时，其中一人抓住了她的手臂把她按倒在地。简当时太痛苦了，她不记得那件事了。
So many people. It was like nine different officers on me, and I was just on the floor. I was just screaming and, like, hitting my head over and over. And I looked over, and I'll never forget this, and I seen Guy on his hands and knees.
那么多人。就像九个不同的警察压在我身上，我只是躺在地上。我只是尖叫，一直不停地撞自己的头。我看了看旁边，我永远不会忘记这一点，我看见盖伊跪在地上。
He was crying.
他在哭。
And he was, like, shaking his head. And I don't know what about that hurt me, and I stopped for a second.
他就像，摇着头。我不知道为什么那件事伤害了我，我停顿了一下。
During this brief pause, the police put a full body restraint wrap, a helmet, and handcuffs on Jane. They put her in a squad car and transferred her to a hospital for psychiatric care. She spent three days there. When she was released, her mom picked her up. As soon as they pulled on the freeway, a text showed up on her mom's phone.
在这短暂的停顿中，警察给“简”戴上了全身约束带、头盔和手铐。他们把她放进警车并送往医院进行精神病护理。她在那里待了三天。出院时，她妈妈接上了她。当他们刚上高速公路时，她妈妈手机上弹出了一条短信。
I hear [DING SOUND] and then she, like [GASP]. She's like, do you want to read that? And I'm just like, OK. I have a smoothie in my hand, like...
我听到[叮的声音]，然后她就像[喘气]。她说，你想读那个吗？我当时只是，好吧。我手里拿着奶昔，就像……
It was a text from one of Jane's attorneys. The jury in von Ehlinger's trial had just come to a verdict.
那是来自“简”的一位律师的短信。冯·埃林格审判的陪审团刚刚达成了裁决。
And she said that he was found guilty.
她说他被判有罪。
And what was, what did that feel like?
那是什么感觉？
I didn't believe it. I was like, no way. What?
我不相信。我心想，不可能。什么？
Why didn't you believe it?
你为什么不相信？
Nobody thought that he would have, oh, just a slap on the wrist he's going to get because he's a good old boy or, there were so many comments. When do you get to hear about a prosecuted, convicted for what they did. And he got that. You know how lucky I am?
没人会想到他会，因为他是个“好男孩”或者什么的，只会得到一点轻微的处罚，有很多评论。你什么时候听说过像他这样被起诉、被定罪的？他确实得到了惩罚。你知道我有多幸运吗？
It's true Jane is the best case scenario for what a rape survivor can get. Von Ehlinger was kicked out of the Idaho Capitol a month and a half after she reported. He was arrested, and a judge sentenced him to 20 years in prison. Less than 3% of sexual assaults ever result in a conviction or incarceration, but the lived reality of best case scenario for Jane hardly feels like a win.
事实证明，“简”对于一个强奸幸存者能得到什么来说确实是最佳案例。冯·埃林格在她举报一个半月后被踢出了爱达荷州国会大厦。他被捕了，法官判处他20年监禁。只有不到3%的性侵案件最终导致定罪或监禁，但对于“简”来说，这“最佳案例”的现实生活几乎感觉不到是一场胜利。
Von Ehlinger still maintains he did nothing wrong. He's appealing his conviction to the state Supreme Court. His sympathizers continue to harass her, and she regularly sees a psychiatrist and a therapist for PTSD. She takes ice baths a few times a week to shock herself into feeling like she's back in her body.
冯·埃林格依然坚持他没做错什么。他正向州最高法院上诉他的判决。他的同情者继续骚扰她，她定期去看精神科医生和心理治疗师以治疗PTSD。她每周洗几次冰水浴，通过冲击让自己感觉回到自己的身体里。
More than two years after the ethics hearing, nothing is preventing another Jane Doe from going through almost the exact same process she did. This really gets to her. The Idaho House and the Senate still have not adopted a sexual harassment or anti-fraternization policy into their rules. They also haven't adopted a specific process for how to investigate future reports of sexual misconduct.
在道德听证会两年多后，没有任何事情能阻止另一个“简·多伊”经历她所经历的几乎完全相同的过程。这真的触动了她。爱达荷州众议院和参议院仍然没有在规则中采纳性骚扰或反办公室恋情政策。他们也没有为如何调查未来的性行为不端报告采纳特定流程。
There are state legislatures that have adopted some best practices. Oregon offers confidential counseling for victims to help them decide what kind of action they want to take, and New York and Oregon use independent external investigators. Neither state requires victims to retell and relive their assault in public. The one improvement Dixon and other Ethics Committee members did make is stronger confidentiality protections for anyone who reports, so anyone who releases a victim's name could face consequences.
有些州立法机构已经采纳了一些最佳实践。俄勒冈州为受害者提供保密咨询，帮助她们决定采取什么行动，纽约州和俄勒冈州使用独立的外部调查员。没有一个州要求受害者在公开场合重述和重温她们的攻击经历。迪克森和其他道德委员会成员确实做出的一个改进是为任何举报人提供更强的保密保护，所以任何泄露受害者名字的人都可能面临后果。
But at the same time, the committee also decided they can cover the legal fees of lawmakers accused of sexual harassment or assault. This is where we are more than five years after #MeToo: more awareness there's a problem, a more immediate sense that you should care and respond when someone reports, but nobody's invented new systems where what a victim actually wants and needs is at the center.
但与此同时，委员会也决定他们可以承担被控性骚扰或袭击的立法者的法律费用。这就是我们在“我也是”运动五年多后所处的境地：更多人意识到这是一个问题，有一种更强烈的紧迫感认为当有人举报时你应该关心并回应，但没有人发明新的制度将受害者真正想要和需要的放在中心。
Part of me was excited. Part of me, like, still admired the state house.
我的一部分对此感到兴奋。另一部分，就像，仍然钦佩州议会。
What was the other part of you?
你的另一部分是什么？
Flat just scared -- like confusion, like scared. I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to. Very scared. Like, I made sure I had running shoes on. I made sure I had, like, stretchy pants, you know.
纯粹的害怕——就像困惑，就像害怕。我不想，我不想要，我不想要。非常害怕。就像，我确保自己穿上了跑鞋。我确保自己穿了那种弹性裤子，你懂吗。
So that you were ready to just...
这样你准备好……
In case I need to run, like, just take precautions. I had somebody, you know, on standby in case I needed to get picked up.
万一我需要跑，就像，只是采取预防措施。我有个人，你知道，在待命以防我需要被接走。
Now, more than two years out from the hearing, Jane's been back at the capitol more than a dozen times. She says sometimes she gets random stares from lobbyists or male representatives who won't look her in the eye, but she doesn't care. In January, she went to the inaugural ball held in the rotunda of the capitol.
现在，离听证会已经两年多过去了，“简”已经回到国会大厦十几次了。她说有时会从游说者或男议员那里得到随意的注视，他们不愿看着她的眼睛，但她不在乎。一月，她参加了在国会大厦圆形大厅举行的就职舞会。
What was it like?
那是什么样的？
It was fun. I mean, I didn't wear heels. I did still wear, like, flats just in case.
很有趣。我的意思是，我没穿高跟鞋。我还是穿了平底鞋，以防万一。
Purposely?
故意的？
Yeah.
是。
She pulled up a video on her phone.
她调出手机里的一段视频。
Look, there's the speaker.
你看，那是议长。
The rotunda's all lit up.
圆形大厅灯火通明。
Yeah, and it was, like, just all fancy. Like, it was just so cool. Then I danced. I danced with some people.
是啊，而且它，就像，非常华丽。就像，太酷了。然后我跳舞了。我和一些人跳了舞。
A representative encouraged her to take a picture back on the House floor.
一位议员鼓励她在众议院议事厅拍张照。
Literally I'm in the Speaker's spot in the House, holding the gavel. Just, she's like, pose, pose for me.
字面意义上，我就坐在众议院议长的位置上，拿着木槌。她就像，摆姿势，为我摆姿势。
I, like, saw you two years ago and you were just like, I can't go back there. And now you've got a gavel.
我两年前见过你，你还说，我不能回那儿去。现在你拿着木槌了。
I know, right? And I wish that, like, I wish things turned out differently.
我知道，对吧？我希望，就像，我希望事情结果能有所不同。
Jane's thought about how different things might be, the alternate life she'd have if the rape had never happened. She'd still be working at the capitol instead of her stepdad's plumbing company. Maybe she'd be an attache, popping into committee meetings for things she wants to learn more about, like Health and Welfare or State Affairs. Instead, she's here -- somewhere between where she intended to be and the very dark place she's been in for the last couple of years. She's just now returning to her original plans.
“简”想过如果事情会有多不同，如果强奸从未发生，她会有怎样的另一种人生。她仍然会在国会大厦工作，而不是在她继父的水管公司。也许她会成为一名专员，为了她想了解更多的事情跳进委员会会议，比如健康福利或州事务。相反，她在这里——介于她原本打算去的地方和过去几年她所处的非常黑暗的地方之间。她刚刚开始回到她最初的计划中。
I'm going to be a lawmaker. You know, I'll never be, I will never have shame walking into that building anymore. Going forward, hell no. Hell no. I'm a multi-generation Idahoan. You know, my mother is here. My siblings are here. My son is here. I'm here. No way you're going to oust me from, I pay my taxes. Like, this is our building.
我要成为一名立法者。你知道，我以后走进那栋楼永远不会再有羞耻感了。展望未来，去他的。去他的。我是多代爱达荷人。你知道，我妈妈在这儿。我的兄弟姐妹在这儿。我的儿子在这儿。我在这儿。没人能把我赶出去，我交了税。就像，这是我们的楼。
Jane's mapping out her path back: PTA, city council, and then the state house.
“简”正在规划她回去的路径：家长会、市议会，然后是州议会。
Miki Meek is a producer on our show. If you've experienced sexual assault and want to talk to somebody, you can reach out to the National Sexual Assault Hotline. 1-800-656-HOPE. If you're having thoughts of suicide, call the National Suicide Prevention Hotline. You do that by dialing 988 on your phone. That's it. Just 988. Fiona Apple recorded this for us.
美纪·米克是我们节目的制片人。如果你经历过性侵并想找人聊聊，可以联系全国性侵犯热线。1-800-656-HOPE。如果你有自杀的想法，请致电全国自杀预防热线。只需在手机上拨打988。就是这样。只需988。菲奥娜·苹果（Fiona Apple）为我们录制了这段音乐。
["HERE WE HAVE IDAHO" BY FIONA APPLE]
["这就是我们爱达荷" - 菲奥娜·苹果]
(SINGING) You've heard of the wonders our land does possess, its beautiful valleys and hills. The majestic forests where nature abounds, we love every nook and rill. And here we have Idaho, winning her way to fame. Silver and gold in the sunlight blaze, and romance lies in her name.
(唱歌) 你听说过我们土地拥有的奇迹，它美丽的峡谷和山丘。自然资源丰富的雄伟森林，我们爱这里的每一个角落和溪流。这就是我们爱达荷，赢得她的成名之路。阳光下闪烁的金银，浪漫就在她的名字里。
Singing, we're singing of you, ah, proudly too, all our lives through we'll go singing, singing of you, singing of Idaho.
唱歌，我们唱着关于你，啊，也自豪地唱着，我们将一生都在歌唱，歌唱着关于你，歌唱着爱达荷。
There's truly one state in this great land of ours where ideals can be realized. The pioneers made it so for you and me, a legacy we'll always prize. And here we have Idaho, winning her way to fame. Silver and gold in the sunlight blaze, and romance lies in her name. Singing, we're singing of you, ah, proudly too, all our lives through we'll go singing, singing of you, singing of Idaho.
在这片伟大的土地上，确实有一个州能实现我们的理想。先驱者们为我们和我们自己创造了这一切，一个我们将永远珍视的遗产。这就是我们爱达荷，赢得她的成名之路。阳光下闪烁的金银，浪漫就在她的名字里。唱歌，我们唱着关于你，啊，也自豪地唱着，我们将一生都在歌唱，歌唱着关于你，歌唱着爱达荷。
OK, so I know that we could have ended the show right here with this song, and in fact, we did plan on ending it right here, but then last week, I did this one more interview that just got to those of us who were putting together the show, and it's an interview with somebody who Jane Doe has been thinking about. A woman who, for a while, was known as Emily Doe. And so here is just one more thing before we go today. This is Act Three. Doe Meet Doe.
好的，我知道我们可以用这首歌结束节目，事实上，我们确实计划在这里结束，但上周，我又做了最后一次采访，这真的很触动我们这些制作节目的人，这是对简·多伊一直在想的一个人的采访。一个曾有一段时间被称为“艾米莉·多伊”的女性。所以今天结束前还有一件事。这是第三幕。多伊遇见多伊。
OK, so while Miki was talking to Jane for this story, Jane was reading this book called Know My Name, and Know My Name was written by a survivor who had been anonymous for several years, and then came out with her name. This is somebody who we had, actually, one quick quote from in the top of the show -- Chanel Miller is her real name.
好的，当美纪为这个故事与“简”交谈时，“简”正在读这本书叫《Know My Name》，《Know My Name》是一个匿名了好几年，然后公开名字的幸存者写的。这是我们在节目开头引用的那个幸存者——香奈儿·米勒是她的真名。
Stanford swimmer Brock Turner sexually assaulted her in 2015, and then she wrote this victim impact statement as Emily Doe, and this statement went online. Millions of people read it. Eighteen members of the House of Representatives -- Democrats and Republicans -- took turns reading it out loud in Congress. It was a thing. And Jane Doe is thinking these days about whether she wants to come out with her real name, and so I talked to Chanel Miller about how she decided to do that, and also what it was like for her to be anonymous as Emily Doe for so long before she did.
斯坦福大学游泳选手布洛克·特纳在2015年性侵了她，然后她以“艾米莉·多伊”的名字写了这份受害者影响声明，这份声明发到了网上。数百万人读了它。众议院的十八名议员——民主党和共和党人——轮流在国会大声朗读。那可是件大事。而简·多伊这些天正在考虑是否要公开自己的真实姓名，所以我与香奈儿·米勒谈了谈她是如何决定这样做的，以及在公开之前她匿名作为艾米莉·多伊这么长时间是什么感觉。
In those four years, less than 10 people in my life knew, and at the time, it was cool that I had the power of invisibility. But long term, what's not cool is when you can't turn the invisibility off, because if you're always invisible, then you just start to slowly dissolve, and just to be in the world and leave such a big part of me at home every day led to such a fragmented experience by the end.
那四年里，我生命中不到10个人知道这件事，当时，能拥有隐身的力量很酷。但长远来看，当你无法关闭隐身功能时，那就不酷了，因为如果你总是隐形的，那么你只会开始慢慢溶解，而仅仅是身处世界，每天把这么大一部分自我留在家里，最终导致了如此碎片化的经历。
Did Emily Doe seem like a person who is separate from you in some way?
艾米莉·多伊看起来像是一个与你某种程度上分离的人吗？
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes.
是的。
Say more about that.
多说点这个。
Well, she's sort of like a beacon and she's very bold. Emily Doe is just this unshakable, clear headed person who didn't take anything from anybody. And I don't know. I am not confrontational. You have to understand, like, in my book, I talk about how when I'm handed change at the grocery store, I just throw it in my bag because I don't want to hold anybody up.
好吧，她就像一座灯塔，而且她非常大胆。艾米莉·多伊只是一个坚不可摧、头脑清晰的人，不接受任何人的东西。我不知道。我不喜欢冲突。你必须理解，比如在我的书里，我谈到了在杂货店找零钱时，我只是把它扔进包里，因为我不想耽误任何人。
I get so nervous. If I'm at a cafe and I have to ask the barista the Wi-Fi password -- rather not. I'll figure out a way to work without internet for an hour. And so in my day-to-day life, I'm someone who is very shrunken most of the time, and it takes a lot to be able to assert myself. I think what's incredible about Emily Doe is that she can show up when she needs to.
我太紧张了。如果我在咖啡馆，我必须问咖啡师Wi-Fi密码——我宁愿不问。我会想办法在没有网络的情况下工作一小时。所以在我日常生活中，我是一个大多数时候都非常畏缩的人，需要很多努力才能坚持自我。我认为艾米莉·多伊不可思议之处在于她能在需要时出现。
Emily Doe takes a stand.
艾米莉·多伊采取立场。
Yes.
是的。
Emily Doe asks for the Wi-Fi password.
艾米莉·多伊会问Wi-Fi密码。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah. Yes.
是的。是的。
And so you're reading about this Emily Doe, who seems so amazing. And it doesn't feel like you.
所以你读到了关于这位艾米莉·多伊的事情，她看起来太棒了。而且这感觉不像是你。
Emily Doe, I don't think, is allowed to make a lot of jokes. Like, she exists in a space that has that -- that can be sensitive, where you want to be really conscious of what you're saying. You want to take care of people. Even now, when people -- people will sometimes see me on the street and burst into tears, and I don't know what that is, but I just -- anytime somebody gives me a compliment, I imagine Emily Doe as this, like, statue, and they give me a flower, and I walk over and put the flower at her feet, and then I come back to myself.
我觉得，艾米莉·多伊不被允许开很多玩笑。就像，她存在于一个有那样的——敏感的空间里，你希望非常意识到你所说的话。你希望照顾别人。即使是现在，当人们——人们有时会在街上见到我然后突然大哭，我不知道那是什么，但我只是——每当有人给我赞美时，我就会想象艾米莉·多伊就像一尊雕像，他们给了我一朵花，然后我走过去把花放在她的脚下，然后回到我自己身上。
So the next thing I want to do is something unusual. Jane Doe from our story has read your book. She read it with interest and she sent these next questions.
所以我想做的下一件事是很不寻常的。我们故事里的“简·多伊”读过你的书。她带着兴趣读了它，并发送了这些接下来的问题。
OK.
好的。
That she would love to hear your answers to.
她非常想听到你的回答。
OK.
好的。
OK. First one. When did you know -- you can totally see where she's coming from in this question, too -- when did you know that you were emotionally and mentally ready to put your real name out there? What were the signs that you were seeing in your own life telling you that you were ready?
好的。第一个。你什么时候知道——你完全可以看出她这个问题是从哪里来的——你什么时候知道自己在情感上和精神上准备好公开自己的真实名字了？你在自己的生活中看到的哪些迹象告诉你你准备好了？
There were so many things I thought were impossible at the beginning that have now become ordinary, and I want her to know that for herself. So I couldn't even verbalize what had happened to me when I was alone in a therapist's office, and I wore a jacket.
开始时我觉得很多事情是不可能的，但现在已经变得普通了，我希望她也能为自己做到。所以我甚至无法在治疗室独自一人时说出发生在我身上的事，而且我当时穿了一件夹克。
This is at the beginning.
这是在开始的时候。
This is at the very beginning. I had wore a jacket with sleeves that covered my hands, and now I can walk in in a regular afternoon, make a recording that will go out to millions of people, and afterward, I will move on to something else.
这是在最开始的时候。我穿了一件袖子遮住我手的夹克，而现在我可以在一个普通的下午走进去，录制一段将发给数百万人的录音，之后，我会继续做别的事。
Recording -- you're talking about this interview we're doing right now.
录音——你说的是我们现在正在做的这次采访。
Correct, but this will not sink me, and by the end, I could get back on my feet so quickly, and so I thought, I don't have to be afraid anymore that something is going to blindside me.
没错，但这不会压垮我，最终，我可以很快地重新站起来，所以我心想，我不再害怕有什么会出其不意地打击我了。
And that's when you knew that you were emotionally and mentally ready to put your name out there?
那就是你知道自己从情感和精神上准备好公开名字的时候？
Yes, I can do this.
是的，我可以做到这一点。
Jane Doe's next question for you is, what's the pros and cons list you made before you came out with your own name?
简·多伊给你的下一个问题是，你在公开自己名字之前列出的优缺点清单是什么？
OK. Cons -- cons is that any time you are Googled, it is the first thing that comes up. It'll be the first thing everybody sees you as. Pros -- pros, I get to be in rooms with people again.
好的。缺点——缺点是每当你被谷歌搜索时，它就是第一个弹出来的东西。那将是每个人看到你的第一印象。优点——优点是，我又可以和别人待在同一个房间里了。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
Like, I don't have to be lonely anymore. I was so lonely. It's so lonely to be hiding this much. Like it's so isolating.
就像，我再也不用感到孤独了。我太孤独了。隐藏这么多太孤独了。就像这太孤立了。
Other cons?
其他缺点？
Feeling exposed. Like it felt like I was in this storm and I had a little tarp covering me, and at any moment, the wind was going to rip the tarp off, and I'm just clenching it down all of the time. And so when it finally rips off, you're like, OK, now I can just give in to it. I can get soaked and see where we go from here.
感到暴露。就像我待在风暴里，我有一块小防水布遮着我，在任何时刻，风都会把防水布撕开，而我一直在紧紧抓住它。所以当它最终撕开时，你会想，好吧，现在我可以顺其自然了。我可以被淋透，看看我们从这里去哪儿。
Are there any other pros or cons?
还有其他优缺点吗？
You know, it is hard -- like every time I'm introduced, there's a trigger warning, and I think that's, there'll probably be one at the top of this episode, and...
你知道，这很困难——就像每次我被介绍时，都有一个触发警告，我想那是，这个节目开头可能也会有一个触发警告，而且……
Wait, you mean every time you're introduced, you mean on the radio or something like that?
等等，你是说每次你被介绍，你是说在广播或者类似的事情上？
Or at an event.
或者在活动上。
At an event?
在活动上？
Yeah, this may be really distressing and I'm sitting there like, what am I about to do to these people?
是啊，这可能非常令人不安，而我坐在那里心想，我打算对这些人做什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I want to be introduced and not have to warn people that I'm about to start speaking, you know?
所以我希望被介绍时不必警告人们我要开始说话了，你懂吗？
OK, this is our last question from Jane Doe.
好的，这是我们简·多伊的最后一个问题。
OK.
好的。
Who is Emily Doe to you now? Is she gone?
艾米莉·多伊对你现在来说是谁？她走了吗？
She's there. She'll definitely always be there.
她在那儿。她肯定会永远在那儿。
Be there as a separate person from you? Still?
作为一个与你分开的人在那儿？依然？
Yes.
是的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. She's a statue.
是啊。她是一尊雕像。
Oh, I thought you might say that, like, you have now, you've integrated her. She's now part of you.
噢，我以为你会说，就像，你已经现在，你已经整合她了。她现在是你的一部分了。
Oh, yeah. I think in the beginning interviews, I said that because it sounds very harmonious.
噢，是啊。我想在最初的采访中，我确实那么说了，因为那听起来非常和谐。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But it's not true.
但这不真实。
That the experience isn't great...
那种经历并不伟大……
OK. All right, noted. That's a lie. Let's move on. She's still out there.
好的。好吧，记下了。那是个谎言。我们继续吧。她依然在外面。
Yeah. I can summon her. (SIGH)
是啊。我可以召唤她。（叹气）
Chanel Miller. Chanel Miller's book, again, is called Know My Name. She's also a visual artist. She did the show art for today's episode that you can see at our website.
香奈儿·米勒。香奈儿·米勒的书，再次重申，叫《Know My Name》。她也是一位视觉艺术家。她为今天的节目做了插图，你可以在我们的网站上看到。
Well the program was produced today by Miki Meek and Valerie Kipnis and edited by Chana Joffe-Walt. People who put together today's program include Chris Benderev, Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Sarah Parrish, Nadia Reiman, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由美纪·米克和瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）制作，由查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）编辑。今天节目组的成员包括克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）、菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、阿拉·穆斯塔法（Alaa Mostafa）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、莎拉·帕里什（Sarah Parrish）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、弗朗西丝·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-特克斯托（Marisa Robertson-Textor）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Annie Hightower, Erika Birch, Melissa Ing, Lindsay Meyer, Nora Cassidy, Kelly Boyle, Rachel Dissell, Michaela Myers, Maria Patrick from the National Women's Law Center, Rebecca Traister, Rick Rossein, Pilar Melendez, James Dawson, Robyn Semian, Andy Slater, and the DART Center for Journalism and Trauma. The musicians who play with Fiona Apple -- Amy Wood, David Garza, Sabastian Steinberg, and John Would.
我们的管理编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。今天特别感谢安妮·海特（Annie Hightower）、埃里卡·伯奇（Erika Birch）、梅丽莎·英（Melissa Ing）、林赛·迈耶（Lindsay Meyer）、诺拉·卡西迪（Nora Cassidy）、凯利·博伊尔（Kelly Boyle）、瑞秋·迪塞尔（Rachel Dissell）、米凯拉·迈尔斯（Michaela Myers）、来自全国妇女法律中心的玛丽亚·帕特里克（Maria Patrick）、丽贝卡·特雷斯特（Rebecca Traister）、里克·罗塞恩（Rick Rossein）、皮拉尔·梅伦德斯（Pilar Melendez）、詹姆斯·道森（James Dawson）、罗宾·塞米安（Robyn Semian）、安迪·斯莱特（Andy Slater）以及DART新闻与创伤中心。与菲奥娜·苹果一起演奏的音乐家——艾米·伍德（Amy Wood）、戴维·加尔萨（David Garza）、萨巴斯蒂安·斯坦伯格（Sabastian Steinberg）和约翰·伍德（John Would）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's been training at a boxing gym, doing some sparring. I keep telling him, stick to your own weight class, but he won't listen.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给各公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。他一直在拳击馆训练，进行一些实战练习。我一直告诉他，坚持你自己的体重等级，但他不听。
So when I get a chance to just, like, go annihilate some little, like, nine year olds, I will.
所以只要有机会去蹂躏一下那些九岁大的孩子，我肯定会去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
["HERE WE HAVE IDAHO" BY FIONA APPLE]
["这就是我们爱达荷" - 菲奥娜·苹果]
(SINGING) Singing, singing of you, singing of Idaho. Singing, singing of you. Singing of Idaho. Singing, singing of you. Singing of Idaho. Singing, singing of you. Singing of Idaho.
(唱歌) 唱歌，歌唱着关于你，歌唱着爱达荷。唱歌，歌唱着关于你。歌唱着爱达荷。唱歌，歌唱着关于你。歌唱着爱达荷。唱歌，歌唱着关于你。歌唱着爱达荷。